uh meeting is House Bill 437 relative to
reading assessment and Intervention
Program
um and um it's I think the second
subcommittee meeting um we've had um and
at our last subcommittee meeting there
was a discussion about um uh various uh
topics uh but one of them was uh College
preparation programs um in State and
um uh that is part of what is in HB
437 is an annual report um by the
department in relation to the um College
preparation programs and um their um
efforts um in um reading
literacy um so I think um Mr applebe
from the Department is here with uh uh a
couple of people I don't know if you all
three want to join at the same
chair just
rest um so
um one of the things we talked about um
last meeting uh I believe was um the
report uh the recent report on College
preparation from the uh
National Council on teacher quality that
they did um and um it was thought uh
that it would be um worthwhile to get
more information on what's going on um
at some of New Hampshire colleges so so
um Mr applebe would you like to
introduce uh who you have with you yes
uh thank you representative cordelli uh
Steven Appleby director educator support
and higher education at the department
of Ed uh with me are administrator Laura
ston King who oversees our educative
preparation programs uh Statewide and
are you still Dean associate Dean
associate Dean Tanya sturz from Keen
State College um who oversees ated preit
at
Keen
great um so uh looking at that teacher
quality um program uh I think that uh
Kean actually had the uh best rating um
in New
Hampshire um so uh would you like to
maybe start things off by telling us um
a little bit about the teacher prep
program at
Keane sure I'm happy to talk about our
programs um do you want me to talk about
it in reference to literacy yes please
um I figured it might help folk because
I could do two hours and just prep um so
in literacy I will say uh I I am the
director of V prep but I was I came to
Keen State um as a professor in special
education and my focus was in literacy
so in about
2016 we created a committee because we
realized the elementary education
program and early childhood need more
needed more in the area of literacy we
didn't feel like our students were truly
prepared so we made some shifts in our
program and I sat on a committee and you
know being the literacy person I was
reading through the stuff you know we
framed our literacy course based on the
national reading panel and what was
evidence Bas and we created a literacy
course that was at a foundation course
that taught the concepts to our students
and it's open to anybody who wants to
take it but mainly our early childhood
and our elementary um candidates would
take this course and it really talked
about literacy developmentally from
birth on it covered you know anything
from when we say literacy from oral
language to reading to writing to all
those areas but it set the foundation so
that they were ready to enter methods
one specifically I'll speak on our
elementary because when they entered our
methods one which is an 8 Credit course
um meaning that they have half Field
Time half instruction time they were
ready to start working on teaching
literacy in the classroom so our methods
one focuses on literacy and social
studies so that was kind of the the
corep of what we did we made those
changes um and the other piece that we
also did is that we made a change in our
elementary ad program where students
could not enter student teaching until
they passed the foundations of reading
test and the practice too so that meant
that they had all those tests under
their belt but it also meant that they
were at that literacy level so that when
they stepped in their student teaching
they were able to step in and teach and
instruct and really get into that
student teaching experience so those are
things that we did I can speak just
specifically to Keen state to help kind
of develop that literacy which we think
is really important for our teachers to
know before they enter the um classroom
does that help okay uh thank you uh so
my understanding um and please correct
me if I'm mistaken but the foundations
of reading
is aligned with the
evidence-based research and science of
reading research that has been done yes
okay go ahead yes I I would add that
that shift for the alignment with the
science of reading and the foundations
of reading assessment didn't happen
until I believe 2016 or
2017 so when you look at Pass rates for
example um you'll see a vast difference
uh prior to the Align with the
assessment and after the okay for the
better yes yes right and I I think the
survey that uh um we looked at I I think
I passed out last time the executive
summary was I think TW 2022 or 23 2022 I
guess probably it was so
okay um would would you like to talk
about uh um generally in the state um
the reading literacy teacher
prep sure so I'm going into my fourth
year I believe um as the administrator
overseeing our Ed prep programs and uh
we currently have 12 institutions uh
that have approved Ed prep programs uh
ironically um two of them do not or one
do not offer LED where the remaining
institutions do um that's said um some
of the work that we just completed was
uh re-examining our approval process uh
for our edep programs and as part of
that along with the onboarding of Kate
mcaffrey who's in the back there um our
our next step will be looking at
examining um some requirements specific
to five different lure areas around uh
the evidence with science of reading um
and implementing those we're hoping to
move those through within the next uh
year um to ensure that there is a
minimum uh expectation of our Ed preps
within the state um and then what would
that look like and how we roll it
out and when you talk about the uh lure
um you are you referring to um specific
licenses for um educator yes positions
so uh currently that would be in
elementary k6 elementary
education Early Childhood special
education special education teacher
Reading Writing teacher and Reading
Writing specialist I listed the
elementary separately in theory it's a
one set of Standards with an additional
requirement for the K8 piece um but it
really is two different licenses so uh
and I just want to weigh in at at this
time uh it is not a requirement
administrative rule uh we're hoping
again over over the next year to that
the state board will move forward with
the proposal to add a requirement of
passing foundations of reading for
special ed teacher and early childhood
special ed teacher today that test is
not a requirement of those two
endorsements it is a requirement of the
two LED endorsements early childhood and
the two Reading Writing Reading Writing
endorsements one of the I would just add
one last thing one of the things in in
relation to our Ed prep programs as part
of the review uh process with and
standards would be looking at uh some
type of mechanism uh to include an
observation during their clinical hours
of uh reading and writing
observation great um any initial
questions
or well I'll I'll ask another one then
um maybe um back to what's going on at
Keen um the uh National Council
survey um looked at VAR the what maybe
referred to as the Five Pillars yep um
which include pheic awareness phonics
fluency vocabulary and comprehensive
comprehension um and looked at them
based on um a number of factors
including instructional hours um and we
sort of uh uh in the legislation mimic
that in terms of what the state is to
report on um annually as from each of
the colleges um could you talk a little
bit about
um those five pillars and um how they're
uh how the instruction is done at
Keen oh wow that's a um that's like a
semester course yeah um well because I
taught the literacy course when we teach
the Five Pillars
and and I will speak when I teach the
course so I can put it on my my my own
name but we want our teachers to
understand the development that happens
in the area of literacy um it doesn't
begin when they enter kindergarten um
and we also don't know and it's
important for future teachers to
understand the developmental piece
because we don't always know what
students are having before they come
into kindergarten so our teachers have
to be prepared for where the students
are and what experiences and what
knowledge they come in with because
that's you can't consequence students
for what they haven't had but you have
to know where they are so you can
develop the skills and help them catch
up um so we talk from uh the importance
of oral language in uh learning um uh
the importance of scribbling and all
these pieces and mimicking what we say
and also the rich vocabulary knowledge
how the words we use with our students
is important and uh reading um books so
these are some of those foundational
things but generally children when they
are in a a preschool setting they get
some of the basics of pheic awareness
phological awareness and the
alphabetical knowledge but not all
students have those experience before
they come into kindergarten which is
another reason why this phonemic
awareness is so important to teach our
students because they have to understand
the difference between phic awareness
and phonics phic awareness is the
manipulation of sounds and individual
sounds and a student ability to break
apart these words into the sound l
really plays this foundation in their
ability to learn phonics and start
decoding and
reading um but also the oral language
and some of those pieces also come into
play when they're learning to read the
rich vocabulary knowledge and also in
the end the ultimate goal is
comprehension so all these pieces
teaching it through a developmental lens
but also teaching how all these aspects
that you talked about the elements play
into this ultimate goal and also
interact with each other is important
because a lot of times teachers will say
oh a student struggling with
comprehension are they struggling with
comprehension you won't know until you
do some of these informal assessments to
really understand what is affecting
their ability to comprehend what they're
reading and it's understanding all these
various elements that allow teachers to
tease apart and develop instruction that
students
um do you
have set number of
um instructional hours uh for instance
um for the different categories
different pillars um how does how does
it work uh practically in terms of um
their course uh work so we don't I know
the nctq does they they look at our
sylli and schedule and then they
calculate ours we break it to have um
equal kind of especially in our literacy
course like time on each of the elements
because they kind of flow into into each
other but then we also know that all
that comes back in our methods where
they review it again but then it becomes
the practical application in the lesson
planning that comes into it they don't
have to take the time in the methods
course to for them to understand the
concepts or to really have some basic
ideas on how to teach it and assess it
they get to take it to that next level
so our instructional hours when we do it
we also think about that wraparound so
they get the first con you know learning
of it in the literacy course it comes
back into methods so there's more
instructional hours and the practical
application and the observations in the
schools um and then the third time it
comes around is in our student teaching
for elementary education where we do
have one of our key assessments that is
tied specifically to literacy there is
actually we do have an observation that
is liter based on teaching literacy um
and it's also for our students to
understand I think the last element to
add is that in our LED program because
it is K to 6 we ensure that um through
our methods one methods 2 and student
teaching that they have different grade
experiences so we try to have it where
they have you know a kindergarten first
and uh a second third and a fourth fifth
so that they not only learn literacy but
they get to experience how it is you
know the focus or what it looks like in
kindergarten versus 2 fourth fifth
six can can I just add I think one of
the things that um is a strength of keen
state is they're very methodical in in
those three components between
introduction of the knowledge and the
skills and the concepts so that would be
part one and then there's a practice of
those and then where they demonstrate
individually and so that there is
purpose in how and when that happens
which I think um Builds on that strength
of learning and and implementing those
teacher prep programs
um there are differences and it depends
on how and when and the emphasis and how
and when that those um skills are put
into place and then subsequently the
evaluation piece that you know there
there's a end component you know an
assessment component from the
institution with the candidates um that
they're analyzing their ability to
demonstrate
explicitly um M yeah represent
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
and uh thank you very much uh uh Dean SZ
for u u uh joining us this morning in
fact your whole your whole team uh today
um I was wondering if we could sort of
step back a little bit from the from the
you know uh teacher prep that you're
doing at keen and and if you could talk
a little bit about um the instructional
methods that are being used by um by
teaching fa you know K3 um teachers
across the state today and um and how
are um our
K3 um students are um you know uh
performing in general and um and what
sort of specific
recommendations um you you have going
forward oh wow
um I think that well so you asked me the
question so I'll speak honestly I think
one of the things and I was reading
through the bill and everything is that
I think a lot of schools because they
want to prepare teachers they rely on
programs and programs aren't the answer
they may have elements that help with
the teaching but what we do is we teach
students how future teachers how to
teach literacy how to base it they know
what needs to be taught and how to use
different elements to truly teach and I
think that it's empowering the teachers
today to go back to that not feel like
they have to rely on programs but rely
on evidence-based practices and and we
do prepare our teachers to come out and
they know they get a chance to to
practice it to to create lessons and to
do it in a classroom but then they enter
a school and if they enter a school
where they're the new teacher it is
difficult to be like wait this is best
practice when maybe they're handed this
is the program we're using at this
school um so I I think that schools are
really doing the best that they can and
they are really working with the diverse
population of students because there's a
lot of things going on in schools that
are Beyond just literacy so I want to
acknowledge that they are working with
the the school the students that are in
their classroom but I think it's
empowering teachers to do what they're
taught to do how do we get it where they
have the ability to look at their
students to do informal assessments to
know what they need and create lessons
that really meet their needs how do we
have these programs that become things
that they can use but not something that
they have to use or how do they use it
that's really best to serve their
students based on the evidence and not
feeling like they just have to use the
program because that's the program that
um was purchased for them to
use clarification on on that thank you
very much um so when you when you talk
about that this empowers teachers to be
able to to to um to use
evidence-based uh instruction practices
are you talking about house bille 437
does that or that your teacher prep um
your your the the training you do and
the the instruction that you provide at
Keen State sets teachers up for that
well I know that our our preparation
does set them up for that I did notice
in the bill and I did read There were
times that you um said instruction which
was really good and then there's times I
saw program so that's where I make that
reference um because I think program you
know and when you think about all the
science of reading and what it came out
it was really an attack on programs that
are being used in the schools not not um
the instruction that is being used in
schools so it's and I think that by
opening it up to instruction it also
allows for professional development to
happen and I know right now the state is
offering the letters program that a lot
of uh teachers are signing up for it
allows teachers to learn those skills
and then start applying them into their
classrooms okay and then another part of
the the question too I want to make sure
we get this question had a lot there a
lot packed into it um is um how are I
mean obviously you know being being
being a a a critical factor in in
preparing teachers and um uh to uh to
work with all of our our kids across the
state um obviously there's a feedback
loop um called how are the kids doing
and uh and I was wonder if you could
talk a little bit about that and and um
and obviously we've been through a lot
over the last few years and we're only
talking you know K3 um in a lot of this
so a lot of these K3 kids all they've
known as pandemic um you know life and
at least in school and um uh but I was
wondering if you could sort of reflect
on that and and also going back maybe
you know over over a longer period cuz
obviously you know we've been teaching
kids long for a long time now and um and
you know Grandparents were kids one days
parents were kids at one time and now
kids are kids yeah so um and you could
just sort of talk about how um how these
these different Generations have been
doing wow um so
it's interesting because when I teach a
literacy course I teach my students I
say when I learned how to read it was
whole language and I remember the
struggles I went through learning how to
read it was and even now when I go to
spell I have to see the word because I
didn't learn how to spell and to read
phonetically even though I learned how
to teach the Next Generation but the
things that I was taught as a child are
still the way that my brain functions
and works and I use that as an example
for my students because I say you know a
lot of us learned how to overcome or how
to navigate some of these things but
imagine what would have happened if I
would have been taught you know bonics
or phic awareness as a child and not
have had those struggles with reading
and writing that I may have encountered
it was something I I definitely gained
strength over my experience in time but
it was something so when I'm teaching
them phonics I said or you know were
doing letter sounds in class I'm sitting
there going this is something I had to
teach myself and this is not something
that's natural which is why I like to
teach it to you so it's something that
you're teaching the Next
Generation and I think that we have a
lot more assessments now that evaluate
students and and there are pros and cons
to standardize assessments you know in
the past we just trusted that the
teachers were teaching and students were
doing well and we took SATs we went to
college and we went on there wasn't this
accountability that we have um in place
now that you know when I was young or
Generations past and there's again pros
and cons everything so standardized
testing there is a value in the data but
it's also a sample of one moment and
it's a sample did the students do what
we know they can do and I and so I
always try to remind my students what
standardized testing is and also that we
want to make sure that we don't overuse
standardized testing because now we have
a lot of students coming into to college
that there they have this aversion to
testing or they come in saying I have
anxiety to testing and all these things
that come in because of this the the
testing that they've experienced so
we're trying to shift that
but understanding that they standardized
testing and my job is to also teach my
students how to do informal assessments
what are these assessments that allow us
to really understand what is happening
with these students they're embedded in
the classroom they don't take over a
class and they really capture students
progression in a more authentic way and
then when it comes to the standardized
testing we know what it is and it's at a
point that we can say okay this is the
the big stamp but it's it's
understanding I think that's the
difference is in our generation we are
trying to become much more informed when
we're creating lessons and knowing where
our students are and really creating
lessons that are differentiated to meet
their needs instead of just teaching to
the whole class and expecting everyone
to be at the same place did that answer
there was a lot
did I answer
anything I I would add to that as I I
call myself a recovering School
administrator I was a school principal
and assistant principal principal intern
for 17 years um I if you have districts
that have the ability and the knowledge
and um staff faculty that are willing
you can really uh capitalize on what uh
Dr stz was just talking about with both
uh response to intervention y or a
multi-tiered systems and support so that
you you're actually able to get to that
granular level of where the students are
at to to fill those gaps or give the
students what they need to get them to
where they need to be and that may mean
that my class of 25
students goes beyond the wall of my 25
that may mean that I'm responsible for
teaching other classroom students and
other teachers are responsible for
teaching mine that there's a collective
share of um the education of the child
rather than it's just one person having
all the skills all it's it's impossible
uh for one individual to have all the
skills that every child needs every year
um with the diverse needs um both
educationally and and otherwise um but
looking at you know those informal
assess ments and benchmarking um and how
you are moving the students um to really
maximize your resources with uh the
student
needs thank you and thanks thanks for
being here I've got a couple questions
one's that's kind of a general one which
um maybe beyond your purview but I'm
concerned about the role that parents
play
play in the reading of their children
learning to
read and you may not have any data on
this but have you looked at the issue of
uh what's happening in in homes for
example uh are parents reading to
children are there books in this are
there books in the home are parents in
fact reading their own books uh as uh to
create a culture of reading uh within
the home so uh do you have that that's
my first General ER question and you
know it's you're smiling so I know
smiling because there are so many layers
to this there there really is there is
evidence about the number of books in
her home and all those things but I
really try to teach my students um why
it's really important for us to
understand that parents in general they
have the best interests for their
children but they may not always have
the capacity or ability to to um do all
these things or time and um
and they may not have have had struggles
themselves so I I I tried to make sure
that when future teachers understand
that our job as Educators is not to
judge families or to say why didn't they
do this but to say where are these
students and what do they need and what
can I do to rich or send books home or
do things that may help the student
continue to grow so it's shifting our
role of looking at what is it that we
can do and um engage in that versus
because there are a lot of things that
happen in the home and and I think that
changing it from why to oh I wonder why
like changing the way that we look at
families because then it became becomes
this schools are supposed to be places
where families feel welcomed and come in
and we work with them and if there's a
judgment or why didn't you do this then
it causes families to not want to be
part of that learning process so our job
is to welcome the families in and find
ways to work together and support them
and find out what they need and what we
can do to help them so I came up because
part of our um this is Kate mcaf from
the Department yeah I oversee the
literacy initiatives and one of our
initiatives is parents so parents on the
love of reading and we had a marketing
company actually survey New Hampshire
parents and surprisingly parents are
reading and they are going to libraries
and they did respond favorably that they
are reading to their children at night
and so we've used that data we are going
to re-evaluate after the campaign to see
if they've increased um as a pre- and a
post assessment but it was pretty
favorable that parents were reading with
their children great thank you very much
the second question do you have some I
was just going to add to um I think it's
also at the school level having been
there it it's about how you encourage
families the the dynamic of even
just I don't want to get in trouble by
my boss um of when I was in school that
a lot of homes were a two parent home uh
with one person most likely staying at
home who had the ability and the time uh
to be able to expose and talk Anders and
um you know go outside of the home and
look at signs and read um in the grocery
store Etc that isn't necessarily the
case nowadays um you know so it is a
huge part of the schools to to help
families understand that reading doesn't
have to be sitting down looking at a
book it can be in the car as you're
driving you know and you're looking at
the signs as you're as you're going by
it can be in the grocery store you know
while you're you're picking out grer
groceries and you know what's listed on
on the box or the bag or whatever that
there are so many elements that families
can do that sometimes they aren't aware
that um that's even part of reading um
and exposing them to students to to the
language and the
vocabulary um of the world around them
um but it it's there is evidence that um
you know the the household is quite
different nowadays most uh parents are
are working parents so that the time
that they have uh to be able to provide
that is is not like it used to be so
schools have taken you know the added
responsibility of you know how do we
help share that and how do we help
support parents with what they do have
with what they do have so thank you so
the second question is I guess directed
that Mr
applebe he was feeling left out as as we
look at this program from Keen State and
you work with other highered
institutions um is their program uh
reflective of what's happening in other
teacher preparation programs around the
state uh thank you for the question I
think um I think Keen is an example of
probably without without inflating their
egos too much probably of our an
Exemplar of what we would look for and
um the other 11 programs you know
there's variations they're good in some
areas they have worked to do in other
areas um you know and and right
ultimately there is always work to do to
improve but I think that you know in the
case of Kean which is I think our second
largest overall program in the state
might be our largest now um but they
would be what everyone should aspire to
thank you I I'm I've got one third one
here so as we look at you know one of
one of the issues that this committee
always has to deal with and that is as
we pass and recommend
legislation U is its impact upon local
decisions and granted there are as you
have indicated there are multiple
approaches uh to looking at at reading
whether it be phonetics whether it be L
the other the open stuff you were
talking about so the question that I
really have U is the is do you feel that
this particular piece of legislation and
we just have got an amendment here from
representative cordellia this morning
but in
general do you view that uh a state
mandate or a state law is needed to
dictate a particular approach to reading
and how does that impact local decision
making as it relates to their review of
their student population Etc and the
needs of that
population
um I I think with reading you know I'm A
literacy person so I I definitely um
want uh all our teachers to be prepared
and to engage and to prepare you know
teach our students these skills I think
my one worry is and I think it would be
important to maybe talk to um you know
Elementary School principles and
teachers is the workload implications um
is this out of work do they have time
because I know that schools are stretch
thin as is and so the only thing that's
only with having the standardized
testing you know I think it says here
what three times a year you know how is
that going to affect their ability to
teach or to to do the work that they
need to do um and understanding too that
a lot of schools now do a universal
screening when they come in as
kindergarten because the goal is not to
say we're identifying students who have
learning disabilities but to know where
students are so that they know how what
what to teach and what the students need
and to to um offer um instruction that
is differentiated for the population
that's coming in so I do think that
having a standardized maybe at the end
of kindergarten I think at the
kindergarten year we have to allow the
teachers to do what they are trained to
do and really help students gain the
skills that may they may not have had
before that um maybe the use of informal
versus standardized more often but I
think this is a conversation to really
have with the teachers and to see what
their days look like and what the impact
classrooms I'm not sure I got an answer
to my question let me let me repeat it
again sure does the state law need to
take place to mandate an approach to
reading Visa local decision making
reflecting of the of the students and
the culture that they bring to
school I don't think there's anything I
I don't have anything against having a
bill just making sure a law for literacy
I just make sure I mean the areas are
evidence-based but making sure the
language is flexible enough that it can
change as evidence you know as the
research continues to change as schools
continue to change so it's supportive
and something that can grow as um
as you know instead of being something
that is timestamped in a moment is that
better yeah and I reiterate that they
already are screening twice a year yes
um kindergarten through third and you're
just adding a midyear or an end of the
yeah repres luno thank you very much Mr
chair um I'd like to um follow up um Dr
STS on on representative Myers's uh uh
question and and really get um really
get specific in terms of what we need to
do um in New Hampshire and um and
section three of um of the um the the
draft amendment that representative
cordelli uh handed out uh you know
establishes a mandate all school
districts which provide Elementary
education shall dot dot dot and and U
and it it it basically uh literacy
instruction instruction shall be
measurable evidence-based reflective
science of reading research and it goes
down and I think um enumerates what what
being reflective of the science uh of
reading research is and um and I want to
sort of flash this up ju deposed with
with some other department um
initiatives that would um would would
reduce or eliminate credentialing in a
lot of um in a lot of areas and I'd like
to get your professional opinion on
what's more important um uh to have in
front of um uh of early you know K3 kids
um would it be more important to have a
specific program that that did something
um and a and a guide that can sort
of move a student through the program or
deliver the cover the content of the of
the program uh or or in your opinion
have a um uh a press a professionally
trained uh instructor that that has a
has a background of knowledge in
evidence-based practices both in terms
of content and instruction and um and
have that person uh in front of um uh
the child being able to um to recognize
the as you said earlier the differences
that that that kid's exhibit well you
know as somebody who um I'm I'm also the
lens your officer I should just have
like a long line of of what I do I
always look at our candidates and say
what I want this teacher what I feel
comfortable with them teaching my own
children right and so I do believe that
we need to have qualified trained
teachers in front of the classroom I do
um that are leading the work in literacy
and I think that will make the bigger
imp act in our schools than just having
a program and I think the problem with
programs is that they never cover
everything it's just it's it's a box
that's brought in and somebody reads it
but there's so many nuances to teaching
that that box can't bring and that's
what qualified teachers do bring to a
classroom um I don't think that and
that's where I said programs can be used
where there's elements used to it but I
think along if you want something that
works in a classroom it's not only
having the qualified teachers and you're
talking kada 3 but it's also preparing
our tutors and Pa professionals to also
support the teacher and the support the
learning in the classroom so I think
there's a tiered level of knowledge that
needs to be in that classroom to really
students um if oh I'm sorry okay I might
be backtracking just a little but um
what I was curious about is uh this
I'm on page four of the updated version
11 Roman numeral 11 about this report
that it sounds like a specific report is
being asked for about these programs
based on the content of this bill but
what my question is is before Mr applebe
you were talking
about the basically how Keen State's
doing a good job and there's 11 other
programs in the state I guess my
question is um and this might just be my
not being a newbie not having read the
whole green book of laws but are there
other evaluations how how are the
programs these 12 then programs um being
evaluated are there other reports so
this would be an additional report being
asked for um where else can you find
information um on the other programs
including sure so the programs are
either reviewed um by the state uh
through a process under a state review
or they can receive national
accreditation
um and that gives them for their
approval and part of that is including
the Ed prep standards that are required
in New Hampshire and at the very
beginning of our conversation today I
explained some of the work that we're
doing now that we're hoping to roll out
in the next 6 to 12 months are including
specific standards relative to science
of reading within our Ed prep programs
and our administrative rules allow us to
do that um to include and then will have
mechanisms uh in place that some of that
will not only be
um how the institutions are
demonstrating where that information is
within their programs um but they report
out on any changes in in rules Etc um
annually to the
department I can just add to that um
sorry the um administrative rules were
recently updated by the state board and
strengthened in this area uh and uh
there's more granularity now in the
rules which should make um Laura's job a
little easier when it comes to reviewing
programs and presenting those findings
to the State Board of Education and
additionally you asked about where you
could find this information uh it is
always included in the monthly State
Board of Education packet any program
reviews that have been completed or in
right good um if I could just mention I
would add to just one L there there is
an annually published uh approval uh for
the programs within the state of New
Hampshire and that is also available on
the department
website and you'll see in there also if
if the institution has obtained full
approval uh conditional approval meaning
there are unmet standards that impact
the program and uh programs that are
being eliminated or closed
out um I just wanted to mention that um
we did incorporate in here that the
department would make available to the
local districts um guidance on
appropriate instructional materials uh
to help the districts in that regard um
and um in terms of the assessments um
beginning middle and end um and between
I've talked to teachers who do it more
frequently um and I actually uh attended
a professional development session um
for um uh teachers involved in reading
and
literacy um and um the presenter was an
assistant superintendent from a district
in Massachusetts who went over what they
did and they had um
extensive data
collected um from these assessments for
each student um that the teachers and
others put into
spreadsheets um to track a student
progress um I'm hoping we wouldn't have
to do that I I believe there there are
products out there that will do much of
that um based on the assessment um I
have this is just one because I was most
most L familiar with that I've got just
a couple of handouts but I can mail it
around um uh this is the company that
does the dible
assessment um and they capture um data
um from that assessment and help build
interventions and um some of the data
that the people in um uh Massachusetts
are trying to have the teachers put into
spreadsheets that done you know
automatically for them in addition to
having a parent portal so you know I
would hope that um we we could move in
the direction of a system like that that
um will um have an automated component
to help uh teachers track uh that
information rather than uh being a data
entry
person
um
uh I was also um feedback was mentioned
I think by David by representative luno
and I was wondering um if you've gotten
feedback
from students who have graduated and
gone into the classroom and I've heard
stories of and you've reiterated
teachers you know learning from what
you've uh taught at keing state but then
maybe finding something different in a
program at the elementary school where
they uh where they have um been hired um
do you get feedback from graduating
students on you know what they're
experiencing in the field uh yes and um
well we we go through a cape national
accreditation and one of the
requirements for our Cape national
accreditation is that we have to for
standard four is follow up on our
completers to evaluate the effectiveness
of our programs and their satisfaction
of our programs and there's also an
Outreach to um uh to our graduates to do
focus groups to ask about like changes
they would make and to their employers
who have hired our graduates so that is
data that we have to collect and we
actually use for our continuous
Improvement and um literacy has not it
was years ago when we made the changes
was one of the things that uh some of
our candidates said that they had wish
they had more preparation and and that's
how we responded as we created a class
that really um added a whole another
level of literacy before they entered
methods so that was one of the things
that we used in response to the feedback
we got from not only our Lum but we also
have what's called an educator
preparation advisory Council that has um
uh my you know a couple of us but it has
uh cooperating professionals that we
work with it has principes it has
superintendent so it has people in the
field so that we get their feedback as
well when we're making um decisions so
we do use that feedback
the feedback uh in our last round for
our Cape accreditation a lot most of
them felt more prepared in the area of
literacy you know the continuous thing
that people always want more of is
classroom management um the behaviors
so thank you yes represent Cornell I I
did have a question about on number five
the certific cert ah certification
renewal um
it's to get your renewal you shall have
passed a subject assessment test I just
was wondering who would make up that
subject assessment test that teachers
would have to to take um prior to being
and I I tell I'm sorry
um at the end number RSA yeah right at
the bottom of the page RSA
yeah I guess I and it just me I may be
out of touch for a while but I haven't
heard of Educators having to take a test
to get their recertification in a long
time orever um and who would make up
that test that's just it's hard enough
to get I think all the credits in the
different areas that you have to get
them in without making a teacher take a
test every three years well I
um So currently to obtain your initial
license in ele El Ed k6 Elementary K8
Early Childhood Ed Reading Writing
teacher and Reading Writing specialist a
candidate has to pass the foundations of
reading exam which Pearson produces um
and this is the exam we spoke about
earlier um that follows the
evidence-based um uh uh research so um
if I understand correctly what's in the
proposal is that um while current
initial license Seekers have to pass
that test we have thousands of
individuals Statewide in positions who
predate that testing requirement which
the State Board put in place about 2015
I believe so prior to that Educators did
not need to take that test as part of
initial
lure so what we have is a significantly
large Workforce currently in the field
which has never taken that test and
therefore
um you know may not have received
training the most upto-date training in
this area so I as I understand in in my
read of this it is that um in order to
to
uh renew a license an educator would
have to show proof of passing this exam
um you know once not every three years
because we don't you know when when
folks apply for a license um they apply
for an elementary Ed k6 license and they
pass their tests if they then later
apply for another endorsement on that
license we don't make them retake the
test that I I don't think it's clear
that it's not every 3 years that they
have to take the test and it doesn't
state that there will be training for
those people to to make sure that they
pass it and it also said sh have passed
a subject assessment test so it's not
really clear what test yeah I um yeah
the intent yeah the intent was um what
uh Mr Al described um and I did not want
to specify uh a specific U name of a
test like the foundations of reading in
there so I just use the subject
assessment test um language um but shall
have passed an assessment test um uh to
my way of thinking you know says once it
doesn't you know doesn't require it
recertify Our advice is always that we
not put specific names whether they be
tests or testing companies into statute
or even administrative rule if possible
because things change and then all of a
sudden we're out of sync with um so
there's a little bit of vagueness
sometimes an administrative rule as well
around um a test U because again if we
we say an exact name and then the
company changes that name now we have a
problem
so thank you yeah so thanks Mr chair and
um and representative Cornell's question
I think is very um important one
certainly um there are you know teachers
who have been um um uh teaching for
quite some time there's new teachers
entering the um uh the field right now
and and I I I I think I'll probably wait
and ask this question for to maybe um I
I see Deb house um uh back there I know
professional development is something
that's very important to her and and um
and to to to to all teachers and you
know you know people people around this
table I was on hotman school board for
12 years so I certainly you know
recognize the number of PD days and
inservice days that U that that we have
and and and um and I think several of
them every year are very well organized
through our teacher organizations um and
uh and I'd be interested in in maybe
learning a little bit more about about
you know the the sort of continuing
education training programs but um but
rather than belaboring that I I just
wanted I wanted to get back to the the
bill House Bill
437 and there's a lot there's a lot
packed into this and and um and you know
just sort of going through the sections
breaking them out um individually
there's a section on assessment on
instruction on reporting on curriculum
and instructional
mandates on dyslexia screening and then
on certificate
renewal and um I I think they're all
loose I think they're all related to um
uh to what representative cordelli uh is
proposing here but um but I'm I'm trying
to uh sort of understand what might give
us the the the the strongest impact to
um to improve literacy
you know um you know for our kids um Le
and leverage the um the instructional PR
the professional instructional practices
that we have you know in our schools uh
today that get the best out of the
continuing education that all school
districts um you know perform uh without
having uh a certain one size fits-all
thing jammed down their throats and um
and I have received some some email from
uh from parents um who really um you
know appreciate the attention on on
early dyslexia screening um and and it
sounds like from from Kate McCaffrey
that um that that we're doing um
assessment right now and that this
would add
a mid or end you know a third a third
assessment so I don't know if if
currently we've got a reading assessment
um in statute because it says here in
section one that it's a new section um
so uh so what what what do we need from
this bill and and and to to Leverage The
Best of what we we have in place now I
can speak to the three times a year so
typically you want to assess at the
beginning of the year to gauge where the
students are a Midway through the year
to see that your supplement or whatever
you've done for RTI or mtss are working
and then an end of the year and the end
of the year is really powerful because
when the kids come back in the summer
it's very telling um where they lose
ground the summer um where where have
they come back in where did they leave
so typically you want to do three times
a year to really get quality assessment
and data speaks for itself data is
supposed to help the teachers guide the
instruction right so teachers need to
understand the data and they need to be
able to understand the different
assessment tools that are available and
to be able to use the tools in their
toolbox to help the children in front of
them so it really sheds light on the KN
and that's really typically why we do
three um in best
practices so is that and and this is a
work session so I'm yeah I apologize for
it getting a little loose so is that
what is spelled
out what what you just talked about is
that what's in Roman 1 and Roman 2 yes
in the fir in the first part of this
bill correct understanding that it would
be three times versus the other dyslexia
legislation which is only done two times
um and then the difference between this
one is there's no secondary assessment
so in the current dyslexia legislation
there is an assessment and then there's
a secondary assessment to triangulate
the data so that's just a little bit of
the difference between the two all so if
we can if we can hop down
to
the the um it's the third page but it's
on the inside not on the back um where
we've got section four screening and
intervention for
dyslexia is that building upon what's
being done right now
to yes so the idea is to screen students
the screener will indicate a flag of
risk then the the teachers will create
an intervention plan which was what the
current legislation had um which is
pretty much mtss or RTI okay and and
make a plan for their for the students
according to the data okay and that's
section four of the bill
yes okay um so that those are the
two those are the parts that of this
bill that I think are in the
assessment category and and those it
sound like make sense to to to you as as
improvements yeah
yes yes I mean three times a year we'll
get that that idea um yes I think
changing the language from a a
standardized assessment to screeners is
a different
um level of assessment and engagement in
the class and it gives a little more
flexibility to the teachers to use what
they're using in the classroom um for
it's kind of what they're doing now um
so and so so is that what this is doing
it changes it from assessment to
screeners well the other the other law
said that it had to be an
evidence-based uh screener for dyslexia
yeah which means it had to be valid and
reliable and has data that it would show
um nationally a risk right so if you're
talking about a valid and reliable
screener it's gone through a peerreview
process um it's gone through multiple
rounds of data collection to become a
valid dyslexia screener um an assessment
and a screener are different so a
reading assessment can be an informal
assessment it could be another tool in
the toolbox um a ctop is technically an
assessment um but it can get into other
areas so there's the two tweaks on those
different
terms so can can I just keep keep sort
of pounding on this a little bit so in
section four where we talk about the
screening and intervention for dyslexia
is that improving upon the existing law
law I think Arlene said we're not
experts at everything in the um in the
in the in the manual it really helps to
have number one is the same so number
one is the same because it says that all
students shall be screened including
English language Learners using an
approved now it says Universal reading
screener um instead of an evidence-based
reading screener so there's a difference
there um and to identify the potential
risks for dyslexia so that is the same
the second part um well it's not it's
not the same because you just said
evence it changes evidence-based to
approve Universal reading screener which
is the the U approved the the screener
that's approved by the Board of
Education and not not not selected by
the local school district as an
evidence-based um yeah so what would be
better to have a universal one or an
evidence-based one an evidence-based
shows that there's reli ility and
validity to the findings um when you use
that type of a screener so would it be
better not to change RSA 200 colon 59
replacing evidence-based with universal
with approved
Universal depends on who's approving the
universal screener right right yeah the
the intent was that um it would match
page right and Roman one on the first
page is a new section as opposed to a
repeal and
replace which is what's in section
four and
so would it would it be fair then to the
be I mean should the screener in I'm
sorry I'm bouncing back between section
one and section four but but if if
evidence-based um if if if being
selected by a trained
professional who's following the law to
select an evidence-based screener would
that be better language in section one
and section 4 than than deferring to the
department to approve a universal
screening
technology well am I allow I mean if the
doe is going to publish like these are
evidence-based
screeners it it gives like a options for
the schools to use but still allows them
to do evidencebased which they would
select anyways but they have to then
turn in the results and each screener is
different so you want to compare apples
to apples versus apples and oranges
right each screener has its strength and
its weakness which were part of the
guidance documents that are dyslexic
committee this summer met and we went
through evidence-based screeners for the
other pending law and so each one has
its strength and weaknesses and I guess
from that point on it's really what it
we want the data to guide the
instruction right and we want to see how
to help the kids so we need to have
something if you're going to have the EV
if you're going to report it should be
Apples to Apples so so in in section one
Roman one it talks about how the
Department of Education shall identify
and contract for a measur measurable
evidence-based Universal reading
screener um and so this isn't a list of
screeners this is a contract um enacted
through the department right the intent
was um um as uh was mentioned an apples
to Apple's um uh provision in this um
for several reasons we want to have a
common base between districts in terms
of um screening and deficiencies and
result
uh plus if we are going to give out um
or make available uh
grants um I think that they have to be
uh based on a common um set of criteria
and a a common um measure um if if the
grant um process is going to have any
validity well well I mean currently the
state provides adequate education grants
to school districts to um uh develop and
and provide instruction is determined by
the local school district um so I mean
it it's it's you know it's not it's not
uniform um it's not a uniform product in
in in every school district it's
reflective of the um of the school
boards and the U the administration and
the teachers and the interest of the
teachers and the parents and the kids in
um uh in these districts so then we
still provide adequate education grants
um without they are based on um
attendance right but but on this um
we're we're making this available um to
students um where they have reading
deficiencies and if we're going to use
that I think there has to be an Apples
to Apples um basis um and uh because
we're not doing this in budget year um
we've changed from um uh a formal Grant
based on those numbers to a competitive
um grant program um uh just because of
the funding issue so a competitive grant
program so that some districts would
receive a grant for um screening for
dyslexia and other districts wouldn't
receive a grant correct it's a
competitive process
um and it's not just for dyslexia it's
for literacy in general yeah right right
um you know so I
I you know I like what I'm hearing in
terms of you know screening three times
uh a year in in in in these Early
Elementary grades that makes a sense
adding a new section where we didn't
have a section
requiring there's no section requiring
screening at all right now right because
this is a new section two times a year
so we're not for dyslexia for d for
dyslexia but this this screens for
literacy three times a year dyslexia and
right right um
so so I I I I guess what I'm saying or
Mr chair I guess I'm saying is I think
what you're offering here has has
there's there's some very good pieces um
in here I think uh some of
it
maybe goes too far by by requiring a
certain uh tool for
assessment
um as as opposed to allowing the
district to choose from different
screening tools that may provide
different uh you know they have you said
they have tradeoffs the different the
different screen I mean I'm not an
expert in this area yes it's on their
New Hampshire guidance um on the
department of of Ed's website where we
went and we reviewed it for 10 areas um
phic awareness phonics and coding and so
there's trade-offs with different
assessment tools so could could it be
and again apologies for being loose
could it be that that one or two
different screening tools might be
really appropriate for conquered but but
some other screening tools might be
really appropriate for
Newport I if I could answer um the ENT
was for the um three times a year with
the um contracted Universal screener but
not
um saying you cannot use any other
screener in the meantime because I've
talked to reading Specialists who um do
assessing um with screeners much more
often than three times a year and if
they want to use a different screener
maybe for specific students to look at a
specific
um deficiencies um that's well within
their um purview and um I I certainly
don't want uh to block any further
assessment along those lines Glen I
think that's really helpful thank you
for for for clarifying that I appreciate
that maybe maybe we want to put some
sort of language like that um in there
that that reaffirms the local school
district's ability to select screeners
to um you know to meet the you know
their you know their needs
screen so I think that helps out a lot
um that's
assessment one one more piece I wanted
to touch on with assessment we have uh
Dr Green here um because one other thing
we wanted to talk about was um the uh
and talking about screeners versus
assessment we've got the third grade
assessment for English language arts and
we wanted to talk about whether how that
is aligned and how that plays into this
as well I think that was something um
you brought up representative Miler last
time so you know we have Dr Green here
to uh to address that that component as
well okay well let's let so so so if I
if I may Mr chair um you know this is
this the this is the last work session
we're having in 437 um if you feel it
necessary to have another one I mean we
might you if we because I I won't
mention one more thing um um we have
been working with u Dr carold Tolman who
is one of the authors of the letters
program okay and happens to live here in
New Hampshire and we've been working
with her and we have another um meeting
with her on the 26th of this month okay
um for what we thought might be final
review of the legislation oh maybe so
maybe we should have a so we could do
another review after we have that
discussion I think that would be I think
that would be great so if if I might
suggest though so that we can get
through this this very meaty and very
technical uh bill that affects how all
of our kids um uh learn if if we could
go down um through through each of the
components assessment interventions
reporting instruction mandates um the
dyslexia screen was part of assessment
and then the uh the certification
certification renewal profession
development and training at the next
session yeah yeah but but go go through
Section by section and and you know sort
of efficiently be able to uh see what we
need to do with this so we'll schu
something forly November I think Rick's
here right now
so yeah great thank you uh first of all
this is uh such an important topic uh we
all we all want our kiddos to be able to
to read appropriately and I want to
thank Glenn for bringing this forward to
us I'm sitting I'm way I'm way out of my
comfort zone here U and I mean I'm
sitting here I'm trying to think about
well how did I learn how to
read and uh although my age my memory is
not as good as it used to be but I can
remember Mr Levine in my fourth grade
putting on my putting on my desk the
book backboard magic because he knew I
wasn't reading very much and he knew I
liked
basketball and so it was backboard magic
that
basically made me a lifelong reader so I
thank him for that um and so the
question I guess I have we've heard the
term the science of
reading is that a gen so the question I
have is that a generic term or is that a
dicta uh for a reading uh so that's
that's one one question the other
question that I have is that on on uh it
would
be
section section
five um
3i uh Glenn you list the issue of of
pman awareness letters of knowledge
understanding alphabetic principles
morphology I've never heard that term
before semantics
syntax how do all those issues fit in
to learning of reading and and the
actual uh training of teachers in these
components so there there really are two
questions one is the science of reading
a dicta a particular philosophy of
reading or is it just a generic term and
then the second piece are these
component parts that you've listed here
does that cover everything or is that a
particular approach uh to reading
because I I don't understand how these
all I'm assuming they all fit together
some way but I don't know whether or not
that's a a program or or whatever so if
you could just clarify it from yeah so
the science of reading is a methodology
it's a meth methology and looking at the
data but also looking at what has been
evidence-based for the Neuroscience in
reading so you can go back to the 80s
you can go back to the National panel
where they reviewed um literature for
what is an evidence-based program which
that means I can take this program and I
can move it to different schools and I
will get the the similar results it's
valid it's reliable it's been
peer-reviewed and it has a clear
methodology so it isn't really a program
it is a method of understanding data and
understanding how children learn to read
and the areas that you mentioned are
considered evidence-based how we learn
to read we learn with semantics we learn
with phology we learn with our letter
and sounds and so there's a lot of
Neuroscience um going all the way back
to shally shaywitz back to um the
national panel and really looking at how
do we best teach children to read and so
that is the science of reading now
people call it different terms some
states call it evidence-based practices
it's really looking at what is working
in schools and what is working they have
sometimes 10 five five Decades of
research right so it's it's really
looking at research from different views
does it have evidence is it reliable and
is it
valid thank you so how does that differ
from what's currently
being what's currently what being done
in schools it depends it depends it
depends I think what's different is that
a lot of people um when the national
reading panel came out there was an call
for um systematic explicit phic
instruction you know and phonic
instruction and I think um some teachers
you know they they wanted to go for more
of a balanced literacy approach where it
wasn't just the phonics that was
clearing there but oh we also want to do
all these things because we also want to
inspire students to read but I think
through that the balance became
unbalanced um and I think that's what's
happening is that there is a want to
inspire students to read but sometimes
the skills or knowledge to teach phonics
is really something you have to learn
and be comfortable with to be able to
teach the Next Generation so I think it
is happening maybe not um as balanced as
it should you know in the levels it
should be but I think that there has
been a lot of shift towards it and to be
honest some of the programs that schools
are using it is not um as evidence-based
or not all the components of it are
really uh aligned with the science of
reading so thank you for that
clarification so but wouldn't you also
agree that some
students learn differently in other
words some could use the whole language
approach for example Visa that of a
phonetic
approach so how does that the the
variance of how students learn how does
that fit into the quote
evidence-based
approach so they're really looking at
the neuroscience and understanding how
uh children learn to read so for
instance we know that the dyslexic
children are running on the frontal
cortex and if we give them an
evidence-based program we actually see
the other areas of the brain begin to
light up that we're at deficit so what
we know from fmri Imaging and from the
research being done with children who um
go under you know brain scans is that
when you give evidence-based instruction
in the orthographic processing area of
the brain begins to activate so that is
what the research says um in regards to
teaching phology it won't harm any child
if you teach phonics um for any child in
the classroom and you know I my students
when they ask me why I say when we teach
fimic awareness and fonics right through
the sound and decoding one sound
teaching them one phon name allows them
to learn and be able to say hundreds of
words if we do Whole language and we
teach one word they learn one
you
and how different areas of the brain
work together in terms of understanding
reading but it also talks about the
difference with
theia and it's a different process
different way the brain works when
there's issues with
yeah one five
so before
bills thank you thank
you
good morning apologize for the
appearance today in jeans and Apollo I
just got back from Colorado and spending
the rest of the day getting ready for a
conference and moving furniture at the
department so a little more casual
today I hope you had a good time in
Colorado it was good yeah
um so one of the questions was raised
last um subcommittee meeting was about
the third grade assessment and if we are
moving in the direction of the
evidence-based science of reading
research um based
instruction um how does that play with
the third grade um assessment that is
being given to students for English
language arts um I think it it plays
really well um because does third grade
State assessments begin and really um
look at what students have learned by
the end of third grade it sort of you
know do students have the skills
necessary to move into that fourth grade
it's the first state assessment that
we're giving when we talking about the
science of reading and a lot of the um
literacy assessments that have been
talked about today that's uh assessments
and building skills for students in the
K first second third grade and measuring
students progress up to the point where
the state assessment would be given so
that's going to build all those
foundational skills that then
theoretically would transfer to student
performance on the state assessment um
the assessment itself isn't necessarily
built for a a k to2 level set of skills
and Frameworks um but I think everything
talked about with this bill builds the
skills necessary for students to be
assessment um so there would have to be
no changes made in terms of the
questions that that are being asked on
the assessment um with uh let's say the
passage of this bill no I don't think
we'd have to make any changes to the
current state assessment
okay further questions for Dr Green
great thank you very much and U let you
go back to moving that furniture around
thank
you um anything else from the
subcommittee um we have uh two minutes
yes good morning I'm Brenda Peters I'm
here on behalf of the international
dyslexia Association Northern New
England Alliance representing Main New
Hampshire and Vermont um I do have some
comments about the um Institutes of
higher education and teacher preparation
programs um I am very concerned about
that because as a reading specialist in
a learning disability specialist I was
never required to teach a child to
read like let that sink
in as a master's degree in Reading as a
reading specialist and learning
disability specialist I never had to
teach a child to read and I didn't know
how I had to go outside of the school
systems the higher education system to
get the training in structured literacy
which the the pillars of um language are
based upon in order to teach a child to
read so I believe all teachers should
have the experience the knowledge and
the ability to teach children to read
especially those who are Specialists so
um there was a comment made that um
about balanced literacy and that
teachers want to teach balanced literacy
they don't want to teach balanced
literacy they want to teach kids to read
and we won't be able to do that with
balanced literacy
um we need to be able to uh teach that
65% of our kids in the classroom are one
or more years below grade level in
reading so it's starting out with our
teacher preparation programs we need our
elementary Educators to be able to walk
into a classroom take all that great
background knowledge they have and apply
it and one hour of observation of them
teaching a reading lesson is not
sufficient these teachers need to have
practice and experience and I keep going
back to Driver's Zed imagine taking
driver ed and doing just the classroom
portion but never driving the car that's
what's happening in our education system
these teachers need to be in and working
oneon-one with a student to see how does
phic awareness work how does Phonics
work how do I pull together semantics
and syntax and comprehension all into a
lesson I know how to do that I learned
it outside of the school system it helps
me pull together all that background
knowledge I got and apply it we need to
be specialists in applic application and
implementation and right now we have a
huge disconnect and I went to a private
school so I didn't go to a state school
but I have trained many many of our
teachers that came out of the state
schools even as reading Specialists who
did not know how to teach a child to
read including those who who struggle so
yes three onethird of the population
will learn no matter what we despite
what we give them but the other
two-thirds need to have this direct
systematic approach to
instruction thank
you any questions for uh Miss
Peters see n thank you very much for
being here and um with that uh I guess
we'll end today's subcommittee meeting
and we'll schedule one for the uh
beginning of November um allowing us to
uh hopefully get something drafted for
our final uh meeting on November 13th um
which will be when the uh full committee
will um vote on this
legislation so um
you you can come back a few more times
if you'd
much
well
the next set of bills which we have
docket okay uh um we're going to be
jumping around with these bills a little
bit here uh the first bill which I'd
like to take up this morning and these
are all six retained bills uh for the
committee of the whole uh the first bill
I'd like to address uh as uh uh Mr
applebe has to be out of here and he has
uh he has uh information for us on
hp55 and that as we discussed this uh at
the previous meeting meeting which we
had on these bills uh back on October
5 um we had discussed uh the need to get
some clarification from uh Mr applebe
regarding um where we go with all the
two parts in this legislation this is a
bill dealing with the relative to the
division of educator support and higher
education and relative to shy
indemnification for private
postsecondary career schools um the
first part of the bill dealt with the
makeup um of the higher uh education
commission and the second part dealt
with theity uh Steve I think we were
concerned with the latter part with the
sh can you deification can you please uh
explain to us uh why that is or isn't or
can be developed later or what have
you thank you uh chair lad uh Steve
applebe director of educator support and
higher education at the department of
um at this time I would
recommend not moving forward with the
shy indemnification piece um I have some
calls out to some Career School owners
who are interested in this change
however uh due to scheduling and timing
getting them here is is they run
businesses so and schools so it's not
always easy to get them here so I would
recommend um we put this off till the
next session next year and we just look
at the makeup of the higher red
commission which is really much more of
a practical issue when we hold higher
red uh commission meetings as I
mentioned I think um back on October 5th
there was another bill that also had
this higher red commission piece in it
um one of the some of the areas that we
run into problems on the commission is
um we don't have the opportunity for
designes for several of the positions
like the chancellors um we have a seat
that we've had for years for a
for-profit college representative we no
longer have any for-profit colleges in
our state um they're all gone so um that
seat perpetually sits open and um based
on the national landscape right now in
higher red we don't anticipate there
being a for-profit college in our state
anytime in the near future and we can
always come back and ask that it be re
added back um so that's that's really
this is you know the commission is more
of a a housekeeping measure to to um uh
clean up some past you know relics of
the past so to speak and what we have
today may be relics in the future seeing
that I think the community college
system meets tomorrow we do yes and the
university system meets tomorrow correct
and looking at uh structuring the
systemwide governance so so we may come
back again with another we may come back
but okay are there further questions
here for from the the group uh uh
regarding this this
Bill yes represent sure so just to just
to review the bidding here uh it would
be to to
bill where's the where's the sh part
that's on page page two at the end on
line section two yeah so it would be
what your recommendation Mr Apple is to
drop section
two yes
and section
one is a you also recommended the
commission may in shall correct and that
was with regards to the grant question
um we don't have a record of the
commission ever pursuing a
grant as a commission um we we did we
look back I I started on the commission
I was on from 2007 to 2017 as a
commissioner and so going back to 2007
the commission is not pursued a
grant uh we could research that further
back that would take staff time in some
hours but um changing that word from
shall which is
fairly RI rigid and um open-ended you
know what Grant what type of
Grant copy the bill in front of you I
don't here let me give you a copy right
here so I know you got to run and if
there's anything that you see within
it isn't it actually dropping the accept
for apply for accept and spend state
grants yeah why why don't you just go
right from page one down through the
membership there and we had some
discussion on all those items and just
tell us from your perspective as the
Director of higher ed where we should
go uh thank you okay so um part two
which is uh there's hereby established a
higher education commission which
consist of the following members um the
suggestion is to add designes to the
chancellor of the community college
system um and you see now this bill
should also add design under number
three Chancellor of the University
system which I believe the other bill
has that language there are two bills
that are very similar um so we would
want we we were hoping to see a design
for number three for the chancellor of
usnh a design for number
four which is the chancell of ccsnh and
a design for number five which is the
commissioner of the Department of UC
ation
um the next change
um was number seven and That Was the
removal of the for-profit
college as I mentioned there aren't any
for-profit colleges currently in our
state and have not been for seven
years
um and then the next suggested change
will be at the top of page two line
one
toate m still no we want to leave number
um where is number four line eight goes
away line8 would go away right that
would be the the suggestion or change
that to May apply
because up up top we say shall which
then implies in number four we shall do
that oh yeah did you see what I'm saying
there so we either want to take out
line8 Al together or add the word May in
there somewhere so that we have the
option
M and then the rest up until and then we
would drop shy indemnification it's just
ruming
yeah are there any other areas and and
the in section two of course is then
taken out of the bill any other
questions of uh Mr applebe at this time
so Rick yeah yeah just um so I I know
when we had the when we had the hearing
I asked about this question um when it
when it comes to state federal and other
grants and and you you said nothing's
nothing's happened for a long time on
that what possibly could the higher
education Commission do with state
grants I I don't have an answer
representative I I mean I
I so can I just provide maybe it's
entirely possible and I I could try and
do some research on this it is entirely
possible that this is hold over language
from when the Office of postsecondary
Education existed prior to 2011 in 2011
the office of postsecondary education
was folded into the Department of
Education but when it was a standalone
entity it also administered a number of
financial aid programs it had other
duties and the and the commission was
different back then they had a much
larger purview um they were much deeper
into program approval in our
institutions and um I know that office
applied for Grants at the time and so
that language may be hold over from that
time right
so so just just asking the question
though if if we if we struck line eight
which is the number four apply
except and the higher education for
commission for whatever reason down the
road wanted to apply for a grant not
having it in there wouldn't bar it from
doing that right no um and in fact what
I would say is the more likely they
would find a grant and they would
instruct my office to apply as
Department yeah because they don't have
staff there you go right so they would
instruct um my team to apply my team of
one and um and we would we would apply
for that Grant 1.5 1.5 okay okay thank
you very much you're welcome any other
questions on this bill I think we have
it nailed down so we can make an
amendment and go forward with what we've
heard today any doubts on that okay
thank you very much you may thank you
one away go on to your business yeah I'd
like to have that
back
okay looking at the docket assets
presented on the board outside the first
bill on there was HB 354 thank you very
much
354 this is the bill that it dealt with
the charter schools receiving School
building Aid and I do have uh today uh
and there was an amendment which came
2308 and I have amending language here
to that Amendment so I'm going to pass
this around so everybody has a copy so
we
CHR I can quickly tell you what I did
from what we had in the previous
Amendment
um I have on lines 25 and 30 deleted
that section where if
um a charter school were to go through
the process of disillusion but they'
first have to have assurity bond up
front uh less
depreciation um what I've done is on 2A
above on line 21 and
22 any Charter Public School to be
improved or constructed using School
building age shall be owned by the
Charter Public School and in the event
of a voluntary or involuntary
dissolution shall be subject to the plan
for disposition of the Charter Public
Schools assets pursuant to
RSA as approved by the State Board of
Education and then if you look down at
part three on the bottom of that
page that was in the amendment the other
day it's just language which is in place
already for all public schools but
Charter Schools been added to it and
incorporated into this legislation so if
they have a a school that does uh
dissolve or due to an involuntary or
voluntary disolution um and they have
this in their um their their their
Charter or their plan for disposition
then if it's within the 20day 20e period
they have to pay back what the the the
public schools are having to pay back uh
that that's that process the business
about the shity bond because they're
receiving their funding in a different
pattern and way than the the school
districts where they get 80% upfront 20%
of the state allocation amount at the
beginning of the project this formula
for the charter schools is different
it's and you can see that's been laid
out um they get 30% % but that's uh a 5%
each year thereafter um uh over the
course of the 20 years so um it it it's
different uh and with that uh
understanding I I I I believe that this
does cover the the the uh the liability
that the state may have the other change
amendment um is really there's no other
change but there were two changes that
were put in this as a result of the
disillusion commission that myself and
represent cordelli and represent fellows
uh uh participated in uh and that's on
the last page on page six these these
two sections under five were in uh where
you have five Z there and under six
Roman 9 that that's in the amendment
that we proposed back on the 5th of
October on
2308 so what this amendment does only
amends that language on the first page
or deletes that section on the first
page everything else Remains the
Same open for discussion represent
Whit thank you chairman glad just a
clarification if I may um on the first
page where you're talking about in line
33 about the repayment that may be waved
uh in line
35 by the Department of Education is is
that the same payment repayment you're
talking about on the last page uh in the
new uh bullet
print so basically the child of school
could be uh free and exempt from any
repayment is that is that am I reading
that ask any any public
school that has uh something happened
within that 20-year period right and
they Clos the school down or Burns or
emergency the commissioner has that
Authority already for the public schools
regular public schools to say you you
don't owe back to the state M that that
same language is applicable to the
Charter Schools same
language thank you and they would pay
back only that amount which they've
received which would be and so there's a
strung over a whole lot it's not like
it's all up front with the public school
which gets that 80 correct right the
this is Strung Out Over a period of
years but those one fault Mr chair yeah
so just to be clear those two pieces
those two uh section then would would
basically eliminate any requirement for
repayment based on the commissioner's
decision yes okay that's right thank you
forgiveness pardon me it would be
forgiveness yeah right as we have in law
right now yeah what's that that's in law
right now yeah yeah
so yeah Corell you had your hand up yeah
thank you just
on the first page that's um alone
forgiveness if there is some kind of um
uh disasterous situation at the school
whereas um the last page section five
really came up as a result of the
dissolution um commission that chairman
lad um uh discussed and in those
meetings we had um the department there
talking about dissolution as well well
as the division of charitable trusts
from the Department of Justice who are
heavily involved um because charter
schools are nonpublic and so have a um
reporting reporting requirement to the
charitable trust and the charitable
trust gets involved if there's any um
dissolution of a charter school through
the bankruptcy process so this really
this um section five um plays into to um
those meetings and those discussions
with the Department of Justice well and
just a little followup to What Glenn
just mentioned is that any other
assets which the the charter school May
owe on or there may be debt the state by
that sentence right there is not going
to be held liable for something that the
charter school has incurred uh this
language in this bill is trying to
address only the obligation to pay back
the school building aid but the the
study committee which uh had senators
and slash Representatives on it uh
agreed we didn't want to be held
accountable for any other assets that's
done through the other organizations
that uh uh Glenn has just spoken to but
the state doesn't want to have that debt
passed down to the to the
state yeah
so thanks thanks r i mean I I
um I'd certainly like to hear more from
the the director of the charitable trust
division with respect to how uh how the
the um liabilities incurred by a 501c3
would somehow acrew to the state I'm I'm
finding a little Preposterous but um but
but I think that that you've what you've
got here in section five has um has
really nothing to do with the the um the
um building aid program but with the the
charter charter school this the section
of law that establishes Charter Schools
not above not not not for building aid
but my question really goes more to the
building Aid and um and you've certainly
got um voluntary and involuntary
dissolution in here in several SE
several places but but how many New
Hampshire Charters have um have
dissolved um so far
one yeah talking since the start since
the start
yeah
yeah and and I and I guess to to to be
fair when when when considering that um
it would be also good to know how many
public school districts have dissolved
so far through voluntary or voluntary
dissolution and Stranded assets well I
doubt if we have a whole lot of public
schools have done that we may have one
that went to a conversion school right
right um but you've got you've got
you've got I mean those are taxpayer
owned as opposed to 501 exactly so you
see what this does it says that this has
to be written into that plan for
disposition of the charter school that's
not in law right now and what we're
doing here is on page two one lines 20
through 24 saying your plan uh when you
put these Charter Schools together the
agreements the charters shall have a
plan for disposition of the charter of
public schools assets uh so they're not
going to get building Aid unless there
place but it's it's not saying in 2A
include restoring you know making the
state whole um it just says that the
we'll be subject to the plan for
disposition it it doesn't say that it
has to be in bolon
3 and you know and and you know while
we're looking up at the number of
Charters that that have gone through
through through dissolution processes it
probably good to know how many did so on
a voluntary basis and how many did so
through bankruptcy which is well you
know through through involuntary process
well both can be bankruptcies but um in
in in both cases both voluntary and
involuntary were any assets um uh
recovered that were distributed to um to
creditors and where would the state be
in If This Were to to be would the would
the state be subordinate to other
creditors or would the state be have
have a you know perfected uh interest in
in all assets not just the building
assets you put something
in well we we of course when we had the
committee study would the dissolution
people with and working with chable
trust and the
director the the is isue that came up
with is that the way to deal with that
and do it quickly was to you we they
aware we had this other Bill dealing
with school building aid for charter
schools which also within that there is
reference to that in the as far as if
it's uh dissolved or the dissolutional
for for I guess Expediting that process
that's why it was attached into this
right here so that it could be really
clarified that really has you know are
you talking about other assets beyond
what has come in as the state has
contributed for building
Aid sure I mean you know every you know
an organization um can have I mean
building land and building are are the
are primary assets of of a lot of
organizations and um and you know
there's going to be other asset there
could be other assets too like um like
you know money in a bank account uh
something like that so so I guess the
the question would be if if a if a
charter with such assets was going
through voluntary or involuntary
dissolution why would be the first
question and what would happen to to
those assets and um and in most cases
particularly if if they had taken out a
um uh a mortgage let's say um to uh to
to construct a facility the um the uh
and I may be getting is the mortgage
holder the bank yeah the mortgage holder
would be listed as the as the number one
creditor and they would be made whole
before any other creditors would be made
whole and other creditors could could be
you know I mean could be Staples could
and yeah but the number one in the
pecking order is going to be the
bank well what we're trying to say is
that we don't want to come down where
all the the revenue or all those assets
are used up and they're still debt and
the state doesn't want to be held liable
for any of that the state doesn't want
to be holding the back that's right and
and
and for the most part and again this
beyond my my
expertise but
but the the first creditor the primary
creditor with the perfected security
interest in the in in in in the assets
um may not even be made whole in a in a
in a bankruptcy and so you don't even
get to number
two you don't even get to wdb Mason and
Staples and Best Buy and Amazon and and
credit cards and
all these other things
um yeah I've been through that with the
Water Commission where I was a
commissioner and there was a lot owed to
the Water Commission for bills that had
not been paid and for piping and all
that we are way down the list we never
got reimbursed for that we had to eat it
we had to write it off um that that was
that was for a a private business who
was a was for a private business
business that had a trailer park right
that owned all the trailers but you know
and uh some of the renters were not
paying the bills Etc so it just slops
down and we as a water district got
caught with that and so but on this
particular situation here this is an ear
area we work with a charitable
trust and it does not necessarily have
to be in this bill if we see that this
language needs further work somehow I'm
good with that because has nothing to do
with you know the other partions already
taken care of on the front page in terms
of the state monies for uh building Aid
so I guess what I'm I guess what I'm
asking Rick is why would we be
considering putting the state in a in a
subordinate position to other um to
other debt in order to provide building
Aid essentially invest in the
construction of a charter school when
we've got a 250 million backlog of
public schools looking for for building
Aid that we haven't been able to to to
to address in the last decade and um
what why would we why would the state be
be taking a you know a put you know
putting its assets at risk when we know
when we invest in the construction of of
public schools the um uh the assets are
dissolution I me just I don't understand
why I I don't think we necessarily are
um per the charitable trusts as I recall
uh chairman um they are involved the
Department of Justice is involved in any
um any such case um and each of those
nonprofit Charter Schools um requires is
required to file paperwork um with the
charitable trusts and that includes a
more
comprehensive um dissolution agreement
than is in the charter school
application Charter School applications
are required to have a dissolution
agreement um as well but um
they're um the uh director there
requ that's sent to the charitable TR
sure sure no I understand all that but
but I I guess it would be good to hear
what what is required by Statute to be
in the dissolution agreement and and to
what extent does the Department of
Justice charitable trust division uh get
involved in during a um during a during
a dissolution um uh case you know my
understanding is charitable trust gets
involved when when you see um nonprofit
mergers among hospitals um because
there's obviously lots of assets
involved here it's not a dissolution
situation but but often times and maybe
more often than not a dissolution is a
result of of um of um uh inability to to
you know um you know for an organization
to meet its obligations and um and you
know the the the charitable trust
division isn't going to be in a position
where it needs to establish a charitable
ER trust um as a result of a zero asset
you know dissolution or a dissolution
where where there's already a um a prime
you know a bank is holding the lean on
an asset that doesn't even cover the
what the you know what the leans for so
I you know what what what's what's
actually required I guess is see the
only part in law right now is what you
see already there in Z what on
Z on on page five six of this uh
amending language you can see what's in
law already on line 11 Charter Public
Schools establishment Provisions for
dissolution of Charter of public schools
including disposition of assets or
amendment of its program plan that's all
it says that's all it says that's law
right now yeah so so it it it it doesn't
say that that the state is always in the
primary position for for asset recovery
or or or anything like that
there's also um law regarding um
Department of Justice and the charitable
trusts um that um you know we didn't
incorporate into here but they are
actively involved in any
dissolution um of a charter school and T
can relate how many but um uh they are
actively involved in that and uh but
they had several people at the meetings
we had um that are involved in in just
that area of expertise so to try to
expedite things here tell we'll get your
report in a second here
um it looks if if this is a hangup on
the bill and which has basically it
doesn't have to be in this bill this is
a request of that committee which meant
to try and get it addressed if we feel
it's not addressed properly it's
actually something probably shouldn't
come to this particular committee if you
talk about the charitable trusts and the
assets of you know of a a charter that's
Commerce that's right and and so but the
other portions that we address uh
address on page one is this seeing that
we're talking about school building Aid
and the reimbursement of what they've
already received on the school building
a it may be if we're you
know you know seeing that there's maybe
more to this story than than you know or
more issues the I know we had the
Department of Justice we also had a
chable trust testifying in that
committee and I know that representative
fellows put through their Hoops pretty
well uh good and so but you know I think
that if if there's if that portion right
there is going to hang this up it really
is
not it's it's there because we had that
one section in law item Z there
Provisions that we just read that's
there and it talks about
disillusion and disposition of assets um
so that it was thought well maybe this
is a good place because that's under
Charter of schools that in this whole
section we're dealing with yeah so so so
Rick I do I do think in order for the
bill to work the bill on um on building
Aid to charters for it to
work that that members would want to
know what the state's risk is is going
to be because we don't have any risk
with with public school dissolution
there is risk with Charter School
dissolution and what is that risk to the
to the state and um um you and
especially in light of the fact that
we've got a $250 million backlog of of
projects that we haven't been able to
you know you know address for a decade
and so if you're trying to to to address
that part in section five on the back on
the back page I'd say this doesn't
answer the question about risk to the
state and um and without language that
um that either requires aity Bond U to
be in place to cover it or you know
something on a on a tapered basis over
the over the years or or something um
that that puts the state in the um in
the primary in in the top spot as a as
the number one and I think the term is
perfected security interest in the
assets represent Luna there were three
recommendations came out of that
committee yeah two of them are
incorporated into this legislation right
here and uh line 18 is also a
recommendation from them when a charter
school closes what happens to Student
Records um do they go back to the
resident District did they go to the
state how this is handled um and that
has been a problem in the past this
legislation as written I think cleans
that up so see there there's several
areas which we're trying to address in a
an expeditious way uh dealing with when
a charter school closes uh it's a little
bit off school building Aid uh and um it
would
uh however I I I
I if we're uncomfortable with either of
those sections in this this bill we
don't have to have them there so so
Ricki Mr chair that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying I'm saying this bill
is missing a section that that takes the
risk off the state in the event of of
dissolution um I have I would have no
problem um striking sections 1 through
four and um and just just going with
section five and six um in here you know
based on the recommendations of the um
of the
dissolution uh committee that the
state's not held liable um to others
debts it's not that the
state this it's not saying that the
state gets paid back you know made whole
for building Grant this saying that the
state would not be held liable for any
outstanding WB Mason debt or something
like that that the charter has in the
event of dissolution uh I don't think
you have to say it but by saying it I
don't think we lose anything and and and
I think um uh uh section six with
respect to Student Records is probably a
good a good section so I have no problem
replacing the bill with uh with five and
six but but until there's until there's
something that that that makes it clear
that the state doesn't end up holding
the bag on on a um uh School building
aid grant that went to a charter school
and we've got $250 million backlog of of
Grants to Public Schools I I can't see
expanding the program well th this this
bill addresses that issue of payback to
the
state on what they receive on the State
Building Aid portion but but it doesn't
mandate anything B in 194 Bon 3 it just
says pursuant to to a dissolution uh
agreement um per 194 B col 3 it's it's
not saying the state has to get paid
back and again going back to dissolution
generally when you're in a involuntary
voluntary dissolution the uh the only
assets left are the um you know the
building and grounds and um and you know
and there may very well be a bank um you
know in there as the first um listed
creditor so I I don't see how the state
gets a dime
back to be I mean I'm just ask how does
the state even get a dime
back
Bel thank you Mr chair and I I tend to
agree perhaps this issue would be better
resolved in Commerce but if we are going
to talk about it we are um I think we
need to examine the full reality of what
would likely occur if we specified
specifically that the state had a had
pracy in any sort of dissolution for
recovering funds the fact is if we were
to put that in the law it's highly
likely that l private lenders would then
view any lending to such such
institution as an unsecured loan which
would which would make them much less
likely eligible to receive private
lending in the first place so I think I
think we need to look at the the broad
issue here and say if we do this if we
were to do that we're probably telling
these charter schools public schools
you're going to have to make a choice
really do you want any Public Funding
here or do you want private funding so I
think that all of it comes back to the
to the fundamental policy issue do we
have a responsibility to fund public
Aid well T L's T T's been sitting there
for a
while hi T bear with the charter school
office um so uh as of
200 uh six there have been eight charter
schools that have closed um just for
context of those eight um one was a
district approved Charter Pace Academy
and that was actually the only School of
those eight that owned a building that
I'm aware of um so just a little context
as of 2006 as of
200000 since 2006 excuse me since 2000
yeah sorry about that so that would this
would include the one
that closed up atate Mall yes a couple
Y okay we're basically now looking at
whether this bill is going to move
forward or not
um and trying to look at some form of a
13th if in fact the latter two sections
five and six were not part of this bill
is the remaining part of the the bill of
people yeah that I
mean five and six Rick are the only
Parts I don't have concern with I I have
concern with the with the remaining part
of the bill with five or six in there or
and or with five or six gone
um because because the there's no se no
part of this bill that um that that
takes risk away from the state
dissolution further discussion represent
Bel I I would just like to take that
view and kind of flip it on its head for
a moment and say yes there obviously is
a risk to the state as they're all with
all public schools however we're getting
the benefit of private lending being
able to fund these schools and keeping
the cost of taxpayers down broadly so
that's that's what we're risking if we
don't move forward with something like
this
further
discussion okay so uh is there any
member of the public that has anything
all uh just real minor um I don't know
if the point is to go through an
amendment approval but I just wanted to
point out One technical um issue and
89 that bold I think should be struck
out that is referring to RSA 19815 U
through W that is for public school
districts um it's the that's the section
that calculates building Aid which goes
through formulas that's a whole section
that determines the amount of building
Aid somebody gets the following
paragraph strictly says simply says that
Charter Schools qualify for 30% so again
it's just a technical
um correction but I would just not put
that bold in on line 89 Page
two because that 19815 U through W does
not apply to Charter
Schools
okay yes so thanks very much Mr chair
thanks very much a um how would um in in
the not the determination of the amount
of the grant but in the in the criteria
for awarding Grant how would um how
would uh how would the department be
looking at at at public schools and
charter schools and and make that
determination as to who gets a grant
there wouldn't there wouldn't be any
difference they all would follow the
same
criteria and that criteria is uh there's
a ranking criteria um the in this law
it's like unsafe conditions um security
consolidation overcrowding ADA
compliance things like that okay and so
the ranking would be it wouldn't have
anything to do with the type of
school yeah all the application process
is the same for the public school and
the Charter Public School um same
criteria um same
law what this is basically saying is
that Charter Public Schools May apply
for a State Building Aid they are a
public
school um qu question uh for you Rick
yeah um when when when the when the
State Board approves a Charter Public
School and um it seems like most of the
charter schools are approved through the
State Board not conversion schools but
um but is there a facilities assessment
as part of that um approval process that
would be a a throwback to Amy at the
department okay um sure so that that
approval process we actually have a a a
new approval process but um so they get
their Charter through the state board
but then prior to student occupancy
there's an approval process for their
facility and it's the same actually for
public district schools for the most
part that Approval Pro there's a couple
minor differences but they still have to
have their emergency operation plan in
place they have to test their building
for asbest they have to test their
drinking water for lead they have to
have a health inspection a fire
inspection they have to meet building
code fire code and the list goes on but
all of those facility requirements are
the same for public schools as public
chartered schools public district
schools and public chartered schools
okay and actually non-public schools as
well except that that that list is
paired down to what's actually
applicable to the nonpublic schools
which is a much more paired down
list okay great thank you very much and
we've had Public Schools regular public
schools theyve had to clean their act up
and and and and and conform to those
that criteria and those standards we
have for square footage for health
safety um and I don't want to mention
the name but we had a school that went
ahead and did some of that and um had to
again so um where we are right now we we
got a number of bills on dock and here
we are already at uh almost
noon uh
so obviously we take a look I would like
to take a look further um and review my
notes that I don't have from the
charitable uh trust and and maybe invite
the charitable trust in uh to address
that issue on the latter side
um it may come down to whether you
support basically the idea a of a
charter school being eligible for State
Building A and if that's where you are
with your principles then obviously I
know where you're going uh but if you're
open to uh Charter Schools receiving
that type of of of funding
support then
um we got to make that we got to enable
that to happen and that's what this
legislation is
about so we'll we'll stop this right now
we will reschedule 354 for another
session uh probably one more session
we've certainly had a number of these
sessions so we'll reschedule this one to
announced okay thank you very much tal
and
Amy okay the next bill which we had was
439 taking from the order that they were
posted
at uh
439 is relative to the duty to provide
an education and contracts with private
schools um there were two sections to
this and um of this bill first part
dealt with 21 inclusive the second part
was a repeal of 189 col 1 - a Roman 4
relative to school board contracts with
non-sectarian private schools to provide
education is
repealed um represent cordellia can you
explain that to us
please um I'm just try to find the bill
go uh yes um this was an area um of law
that was left out of our previous um
attempts to extend uh services to
special education students until their
22nd
birthday um so it was found um sorry it
was found by uh someone pointed it out
to us and hence um this uh language just
to make it consistent with the other
language that we had put in statute uh a
year or so
ago then this part the bottom part there
right here which
references oh that law right there yes
um yeah this is um in relation to um
manifest education
hardship um and that um that was also
left out um in terms of when we removed
non sectarian schools uh language from
elsewhere in in statute um so to be
consistent we wanted to do that here for
the um uh manifest education hardship
this yes go ahead so on on
439 is it saying that um that that any
in it should be the D School Board to
provide addition Elementary sector
education can remain in SEC let's just
say secondary education because I don't
think we're going get too many 21 year
olds at elementary but can remain in a
in a secondary school program program um
uh until they turn 21 22 it's 20 all
right until they turn until they turn 22
correct yes so it's basically saying
saying if I wanted
to stay in
school and keep taking whatever classes
that we're not going to
um meet graduation requirements for that
school I could continue to take those
classes until I turn 22 correct okay so
every school district would have an
obligation to every student not just
special education which is the
law well this
is right this is specific to speci
education
students sorry
yeah the first part the first Roman
numeral on on under that law deals with
and it said age 21 and it it wasn't age
21 inclusive and we've gone through that
battle many many many times so that
changes that the second part it jumps
through from 2 3 to 4 and it it
eliminates section
four and I had some questions as to why
that's why I'm bringing it up uh as to
why that is being repealed in this
bill that's a
too why don't you read that section to
everybody so they can hear
it uh this is under Duty provide
education
1891 a uh Roman 4 pursuant to RSA 193
col 3 Roman 6 a school board May execute
a contract with an approved
non-sectarian private school approved by
the school board is a school tuition
program as defined in
193 col 37 to provide for the education
of a child who resides in a district and
may raise appropriate money for the
purposes of the contract if the school
does not have a public school at the
pupil's grade level and the school board
decides it is in the best interest of
the
child so
this goes to the
um Town tuition programs they don't have
a um a grade level they can um
execute a
contract um with
a secretari and school as well as non-
sectarian school that be a religious
school
correct by eliminating that Roman four
though are we eliminating the capability
it it's one of these areas of law that
it's I understand the intent which maybe
it was set for but are we also now
taking away that that legislation
enabling a district to contract with
some other District to take these
children because they don't have that
grade level within their ascending
receiving ascending District so are we
taking that capability away from the
district I I don't believe so I think
this is just um related um to that that
basically that one provision I'll look
statue yes represent gu Cen uh thank you
I'm a little confused on that too cuz
you mentioned manifest educational
hardship which is a process right to get
to that um and was this line eight and
nine already in the current
statute or is it new to this bill that
we're removing something I understand
the 21st up to 22nd yeah I mean that's
been we've been doing that pretty
consistently to apply um the way it
needs to be
but if this is repealed does that take
some Authority away from the local board
I don't I don't know I just need more
clarification on
it because a board would engage in a
contract no matter what kind of learning
yeah see OPP confused to that it says in
in the part two of this legislation
relative to school board contracts with
non- secretari and private schools to
provide education is
repealed um so if you are a district and
you have a child that's gone through the
best interest and all that you yet
manifest education and a hardship and
it's been approved by that local board
and they're looking now to try send this
child to another receiving
District can they do that if in fact
we're saying
um the that section law is
repeal why is it this I don't believe
that's in the current law I'm not
finding it under
1-A it goes up to a section three no
there's a section four or is there a
section four okay then I'm not on the
right we've got I've got it right here
okay
yeah right so Rick
yes so looking at
you know this one of those things where
where I think we've got duplicative you
know a lot of duplicative language in
the law and and
1A Roman 4 refers to 193 colum 3 Romans
6 and Romans
6 reads if there's no public school for
the child's grade in the Resident
District the school board May contract
so very similar language with another
Public School in another school district
or with any private school so not just a
non sectarian private school and offer
references Roman 7 what's that it does
Roman 6 and Roman
to well because it puts the requirement
that it be a be a non-sectarian school
school means the contract could be with
the religious school and we have the
1933 where we made the change so that
they can contract with any private
school as was as was
read so this does not need to be in
discussion okay I think we need to just
you know make sure that we're not
undoing something that we don't want to
arms thank God for this annotative
version thank you it it basically says
that 1933 used to say
what the one we're trying to repeal now
said right and so I think you can see
that they already did this in one place
and still hanging over here in the other
and so therefore this is a it's another
area where we missed one section of
Statute because we made the change in
1933 to say any private school yeah and
that got signed into law but we missed
um this section in 189 didn't take it
out and didn't right okay further
discussion okay I think with you
know everybody should be looking at it
and you know we'll you know is there
anybody that's objecting to this bill
right now then one um um yes
representative I'm not clear on that
piece so there we need more clarity then
okay okay we try and get that and make
it available when we're discussing this
on November
13th
or it when we come back to further
treatment before we could have it at the
same time need more clarity okay next
one which we had in the order of of
where we are here uh just did
U
uh
SV
25 it's the next one I think on the list
out in the hallway didn't we
already uh yes um the decision on that
was there two
um I I as I recall I think maybe we held
on to this in case not knowing what
would happen on the other
side right yeah so this one we don't we
don't need this bill it's
duplicative okay so we're done with the
uh 25 25 which one 25
yeah
okay okay
627 this is relative to local education
Improvement plans and disparities in
education that was represent lexus's
Bill uh it was very complex I think it
was trying to redo 193
h and we know that we've had a long
discussion regarding this on the others
um what's the feeling of the committee
on
it yes thank you way back when in in uh
we first heard that in in back in
February under section two on page page
three the question of disparity was we
supposed to be getting a definition do
we ever get to Define what persistent
disparity was
that I'm on page page two hope line 21
we'd ask for a definition of persistent
disparity I didn't know if that came in
months I the the whole area we're trying
to model I here is that through one bill
we're tackling an awful
lot and it's it's overwhelming it's just
like 266 was right and and I don't think
we're at that point where we need to be
rewriting Improvement plans and the
assessment and Improvement
plan
uh looking at section 193 C 193
h
a lot of that has to do too with our
federal plan or application processa
Essa M Mike got feeling is on this one
right here it's um it's a step too far
at this point in time I yeah I agree
with that too and and during during the
hearing I think um representative leakas
mentioned that that much of the language
had taken from a bill that I had
sponsored a couple years ago um I
thinkability section yeah I think this
language by itself doesn't hold um uh
it's it's really part of more
comprehensive changes that consider
consider this accountability as part of
what's being funded um in education so I
I I agree with the chair so I I think
the recommendation ought to be itl in
this is there any objection nope okay go
um uh see uh no we did 155 147 HP 147
bill and the makeup of that Council
on
so we do have several amendments on that
we had an amendment by representative
Tanner we have a representative uh
cordelli
Amendment does everybody have a copy of
meeting um excuse excuse me chair yes um
I was I'm sorry I'm a little late uh
there were two amendments so uh Lyndon
representative Tanner and I drafted yes
and I don't know if they've made it up
here yet um she was going to they there
was a delay and putting them together
uhhuh do you have any so we don't have
that here right now so that that's still
an NOS you're saying I think so wow it's
taken them a long time
yeah I
could is that was that to replace uh
Linda's 147 Amendment or addition to is
it there yeah I I think it's it's a new
one that was directed by the committee
uh for us to put together at the last
session and basically what it did is it
removed one one member of the Senate
yeah um it was uh designed to uh allow
people to serve dual roles as both the
parent and a different like a a teacher
or a representative like that and it was
uh the third part of it was to um add a
medical uh professional and but we
prepared it twice two different ways one
with the medical professional and one
without um and since that time we've
gotten a lot of different feedback uh so
representative Tanner and I have been
looking at that Amendment again and in
particular looking at that dual rooll
piece because uh since our last meeting
we've gotten a lot of feedback from uh
different parent Representatives that
that's not really what they're
interested in um the issue isn't really
so much the Quorum it's more the
majority itself um and they feel that by
um putting in a dual role it would um
kind of dilute the parent representative
role so in looking at the amendment that
is being drafted currently we've taken
that piece
out thank you
further comments about this bill here
from the committee yes represent Damon
thank you and my apologies for being
late um I would like to speak in favor
of including the medical professional
not necessarily a physician but a
licensed health care provider primary
care provider um both because I
initially thought that that was valuable
but also I've had a lot of feedback from
um the population that they
would prefer that to be the case and see
it um chair excuse me I believe the uh
provider is there any objection to
putting a health care provider on that
Council I don't think there is the
feedback I have yeah gotten is
supportive of that as well
okay so when you're doing your Amendment
make sure that's in there that repres
U so it was it the direction of the
committee then perhaps just put the one
Amendment with including the healthc
care provider and not do the one without
the healthcare provider yeah now what
are the other two components that you've
added you know you took out one Senator
right or or or one one was it a senator
yeah essentially that there's one
Senator out and and basically if we
remove all the language about the Dual
role it reverts back to the original
language that would be in there and the
only other addition was uh the election
of the uh chairperson uh Vice chair and
the
clerk okay now represent Cordell you had
in your Amendment you I don't believe
you were at that meeting were you when
we had that discussion last time maybe I
don't know maybe you were I I think you
were at the vets that day yeah okay um
you have scratched out on your Amendment
yes everybody have a copy of repesent
309 309
20 just the one that's 239
23099 October 5th yeah 2309 was the one
that was put last 239 309
yeah 2309 is Right dated October 5th
correct October 5th
okay October 5th Glen what's the day of
the latest one October 8th
oh so this so EXC mine says October 5th
mine
too so is there a difference between the
October 5th Amendment October 8
Amendment um
the number is uh the same though it's uh
uh
2309 is that same number but different
date that's weird yeah that is wait a
minute 108 October 5th which one October
5th
108 I think it's the way we're reading
it it says 108 underneath oh yeah
right yes October 5th yes I'm okay can
you explain what what you have there
this uh go over the changes in this
um uh it makes it 16 individuals with
disabilities or parents of children with
disabilities um it makes it two members
of the House of Representative
Representatives appointed by the Speaker
of the House one member of the
Senate it removed moves um one local
education official who shall be an
administrator appointed by the
governor it changes two teachers to one
teacher who is a special ed
teacher that's in
um the revised
F uh
then it removes the representatives of
the disability rights Center and the
parent information
center it changes
two individuals with
disabilities who have received services
individual
um and then further down with the
Department of Corrections it makes it um
one representative the from the
Department of Corrections who is
education and then the um the addition
of the clerk to be appointed and the
discussed yes Co then represent Damon
thank you BL can you clarify on why the
deletion of the the uh parent
information center or disability rights
um I I think that
um from my experience it's it's more
important
sorry I should be in practice by now um
it's more important the focus of the
federal law is a majority of
parents and that should be the focus um
I I don't think that the um
representatives of those two
organizations ations um are in the um
Forefront of um what uh the uh
commission is tasked with doing um I
think the uh primary focus should be the
uh the parents there um and teachers um
Etc who are directly in involved in in
special
education um so I I don't think that
they are are um required in this Prov in
this uh uh in this Council and they are
not um required under federal law either
we Tred to stick more with what's
required in under federal law um with
these changes thank
you represent Damon did you have your
hand
up I had the same question as
representative Woodcock and also wanted
to know in the amendment from
representative Tanner and balbon what
you folks did with those two positions
disability rights and parent
information um the uh amendment that we
put together kept those two positions
in thank
you representative
cascaden oops thank you Mr chair I'm
just curious
um if if you know why DRC and pick were
included in the law
initially um they are the first
resources to provide to
parents
um and really add Clarity sometimes to
problem
solve um some very serious
issues so do you know why it was in
there initially was what was the role
and what was the function and why is
there no need for it
I I don't know um I I think uh they were
added um before my time so I'm not sure
um you know why they they were added but
I think that uh in terms of the parent
information center they do things um
other than uh special ed
education um so uh I think that that's
one reason that uh um uh the other
representative and I um I felt it was
necessary to remove it and from our
experience I I was a member for several
terms um and representative katab is uh
SAC yes representa
dry thank you uh representative cordelli
how many people would be on the
committee if you adopted your
Amendment um uh I think it was something
like 24
I'm getting a lot higher number just
going this counted it
yeah only now I can't remember it
counted it with disability rights and
parent info center it comes out to the
16 parents and 19 other people yeah so I
think I have that right so without it
would be 17 to 16 so it's still either
way it's not a parent majority right all
followup please yeah so the idea I
thought of this bill was to make this
committee function and it's not
functioning at the large size that it's
at so we're just rearranging the deck
chairs on the Titanic here that that was
the original purpose of the bill um was
to shrink it and keep apparent majority
um because of the
dysfunction um that uh uh
parents um and legislators um have
viewed over a period of
time and I think any any committee or
commission with 36 38
commers um even trying to get a quorum
um whether it's online in person um and
trying to respect the opinions and get
um feedback at meetings from 38 people
is uh quite an obstacle to having an
efficient meeting uh especially you know
trying to get a meeting done even within
two hours um is a chore and uh um that's
why um uh truthfully when representative
katab said she was interested I I said
place represent
Bon um I just want to refer back to a
lot of the feedback that I've gotten
from a lot of the parent Representatives
that are on the committee uh they feel
that the committee has really not is not
effectively representing the concerns of
the parents and I believe what they're
trying to achieve with this is to make
sure that it goes back to a parent
majority and that the focus is on the
parents concerns now I can't speak to
how that dysfunction arose and I've
heard differing um opinions about what's
going on but it seems clear to me that
they feel like they're not getting the
appropriate data that they need to make
informed decisions and um that perhaps
they're not getting uh the support that
they need from the Department of
Education so one of the things that uh
representative Tanner and I were also
looking into was making sure that they
had funds that were available to help
with workshops and to bring in speakers
and and resources that they can use to
help get the information that they need
to make those
decisions uh just just uh one comment
here um a number of our committees when
we put them together we have technical
support placed on these committees as
nonvoting members other words they're
there to provide assistance and
support um oftentimes like for example
in CTE advisory counil we have Jeff
there to provide us the guidance in fact
Jeff even shares it um then we had just
a a a a group dealing with teacher
shortage and we had Steve Apple be there
to give us technical support throughout
um so if if the primary purpose for some
of the organizations to be there is to
provide support to parents they don't
necessarily have to be a voting member
they can be there and contribute and be
very active participants so that's
something we might want to consider as
well go ahead represent cordelli thank
you um I think I think that's one reason
um that we had uh added the appointment
of a clerk um I I think my experience um
the council went way overboard in
looking for um staff from the Department
of Education um to provide services for
them I I went to the commissioner on a
number of occasions about that myself
because it was not um called for in
Statute in any way shape or form and to
have um of special education or somebody
else um uh along those lines taking
minutes for them I think was uh way out
of bounds and so that they should
appoint their own clerk to do their own
minutes representative cascaden and
representative Cornell um I think it
would make sense for me then to amend
um line 27 2829 the the DRC and Pi pic
to be members of this committee in a
nonvoting capacity or advisory but they
should be included
somehow um but really the final decision
on the information that they glean would
be with the
parents yeah we've often times just
written as non- voting
members uh so they're members but
they're not voting it's we we we do that
in a number of capacities for example
even a student on a school board may not
vote on some issues which are dealing
with staff and personal confidential
information so um representative Cornell
you had and then representative Pell um
at our our last subcommittee meeting we
spent a great deal of time on this and
um I think a couple of the things like
two
teachers I I think it said in federal
law that you had to have two for this
commission that's why we put instead of
one we put back the two and I think the
other one was the one individual with
the disabilities I think it was that one
that was two individuals is in law um
federal law that that has to be on the
advisory Council and then we had a long
discussion about the um County
Corrections because many times um a a
young person with disabilities will be
placed in the County Corrections for a
year and if they aren't getting any kind
of special education that really is
against the law um because they're still
under 21 so they should be still getting
it and that you could spend quite a bit
of time in in County Corrections and
also the the disabilities in the par and
information center I I can remember from
when I was a school counselor that
especially the parent information center
would come and with the parent and
student as their representative to make
sure that their rights were being um
heard at the school um to make sure that
the school was wasn't you know not
providing everything that they were
entitled to so I always saw them as a a
special
education student and parent
representative um for that so thank you
representative panel thank you is this
committee open to the
public yes well it is if if I you know
if you know we see we we need that
support because it's not technically a
hearing this is a work session of the
full committee we've had the hearings on
this bill no this not the committee
we're in right now this committee that
we're
discussing um I I I've been there and
it's over the years it's been managed
differently well I guess what I'm saying
is if these positions that the the
positions we're discussing removing they
could always attend the meetings of sack
and offer
input
attend not if you're not on the on the
committee or the council you got to be
recognized nor to speak so if somebody
wanted to ask their advice off request
and offer of input or they could it's
like the school board sometimes you just
got to get on the
docket yeah represent Myer well thank
you I mean obviously this is a a large
body to get together to try to do any
kind of work and I sensitive to that but
you know for the um 12 years I've been
on this committee uh both the dis
disability rights Center and the parent
information center have provided
valuable information to this committee
on on the topics that they deal with and
I I don't understand I understand the
the trying to get the numbers down but
their resources has been so valuable to
this community to this group it's I I
would hate like heck to have them not be
able to sit at the
table um I'm assuming this committee
makes
decisions and so if they're going to
make decisions they want to make
informed decisions I guess they could
these folks these Representatives could
attend and try to get their hand in but
you know as well as I that if you don't
have a t if you don't have a seat at the
table and a right to
vote the information can just go out
there without not not really being taken
seriously so I do have uh Glenn I have a
real concern about them not being there
because of the what's been said here is
far as how they advocate for parents Etc
they may not be parents but they do
advocate for families Etc and so I I've
got serious concerns about the removal
of them from this committee okay there
there there's one issue I think we need
to address or attend to uh for example
we have committees which require that a
school administrator be a member of the
committee and just many
committees and then you ask your do we
ask ourselves should we allow the
lobbyists from the school administrators
Association be it maybe um um Mark mlan
now who is the you know the
director of that I don't know if he's a
lobbyist or if Jerry fu is a lobbyist or
uh I know that in school boards
Association Barett Christina is a
lobbyist but it's but we oftentimes have
a school board member put on a committee
of type but not necessarily one right
out of the office who's the lobbyist
should a lobbyist be placed in on a a
group like this or should be a member of
that Association or organ you
member lobbyist or somebody from the
organization lobbyist might be a member
organization but they're also you know
I understand your your your comment uh
direct I just understand is there anyone
on this listing uh this volume of folks
here that are categorized as lobbyists I
didn't see that we can ask the group
right here on the on the the numbers
that Glenn had and the ones we have
there there's two organizations we're
talking about right the display rights
Center and the parent information center
right right does the disability rights
Center have a lobbyist
yes an attendance today right now if you
were have a member are do you have a
second come on up
okay good morning still morning I'm
Karen Rosenberg I'm the policy director
actually it's not still morning I'm the
policy director at the disability rights
Center and I've been at the disability
rights Center for about 18 years now
first as an attorney senior staff
attorney representing um children
through their parents in a variety of
matters but really specializing in
Education cases for children with
disabilities a couple years ago our
policy director retired and so I am now
the policy director and as such I have
registered as a lobbyist my the only
lobbying I do however is on behalf of
the disability rights Center my employer
always consistent with our strategic
plan the our organization's mission
which is to advocate for the rights of
individuals with disabilities that
includes the students and their parents
represent so is there a conflict if
you're also a lobbyist and a participant
on a council like this I don't see a
conflict the AG's office was asked to
weigh in on this they did not see a
conflict I'm still me right I am still
an employee of the disability rights
Center I have like I and the and my
education and this you know the amount
of work I've done to learn education law
and what the rights are under federal
and state law for children with
disabilities has remained consistent and
I'm not it's not like I am lobbying for
anybody else if I was also employed and
lobbing for an organization that had
interests that were contrary to the
interests of the disability rights
Center so that I can not necessarily
consistently represent our
organizations's interest and role in
this organization I could see a conflict
but I don't see a conflict there where
all I'm doing is advancing you know our
organization's Mission which is to
ensure that the rights of people with
disabilities are
met further
questions thank
question just got another
question okay so it's not to Karen then
not to Ken okay thank you very much
Karen
represent Bon do you have a question um
yes I do thank you thank you chair um
I'm just curious though if you did not
have that position would there be
somebody else who was not a lobbyist
that could take the position
representing your
organization um I don't I don't know
that there would be another person who
would be a be available right now to
step into this role we have really
limited resources I think that I was
appointed because of my expertise and
experience representing parent parents
well children through their parents and
education matters so um I I can't answer
that
question thank
you did your
predecessor was he a lobbyist I believe
he was registered as a lobbyist so my
predecessor was our former executive
director dick Cohen and
I'm 80 85% sure he also was a registered
lobbyist but MH um you you all may know
better than me actually who would no
Bonnie
probably okay further questions of of
Karen it's not so much for Karen but if
what you're lobbying for is students and
families with disabilities to get their
rights that I don't I don't see that as
guess I I I think that this even goes to
the level of Beyond us right here
because this is uh uh every committee's
could possibly have this question asked
and probably it has to be addressed by
another
attorney um that's employed by the
house I in fact it may have been I don't
know I I just want to be walking very
carefully represent Damon and then thank
you Mr chair and thank you um so I was
just going to articulate in the Federal
regul ation it says the state must
establish and maintain an advisory panel
for the purpose of providing policy
Guidance with respect to special
education and related services for
children with disabilities in the
state would I be correct in thinking
that that is in fact a major purpose of
your organization yes and it's also a
big part of what I do as the policy
director disability rights
Center so I Echo representative cor
Cornell this seems completely compatible
and and not a conflict of interest also
follow up one more you did say that the
Attorney General reviewed that so this
had been asked and the there's an an
Assistant Attorney General was asked um
this very question and I don't know if
she's still with the AG's office but she
came to a meeting that we had and said
that she did not see a
conflict are you talking about an it it
yeah I I don't remember who it was but
it was someone who followed Chris Bond
office yeah that was a Liz yeah yeah
okay she went to doe yeah okay uh
further questions of
Karen represent Noble you no not not of
Karen okay thank you thank you very much
thank you represent
Noble thank you Mr chair I I think it we
might have some parents that are on the
um committee and is it possible that we
could hear their opinion on this you
[Music]
forward hi my name is Karen Stokes and
the current chair of the sac committee
so I was able to watch the video from
the last time um so I was just here if
anybody had any questions relating to
the current sack
makeup so I'll ask you a question we you
heard a lot of suggestions as who should
or should not be on the council yes as
chair of the council what's your
recommendation so I was looking at the
numbers and I do want to make sure that
you are aware that there's currently 22
positions that are not parent positions
so when you look at the makeup if you
added 16 that still would not give us
the parent makeup um after having
conversations with multiple again I'm
just the parent so I don't represent the
full sack I just want to make sure I say
that um so we would need more than 16 in
order to get a parent majority um and
they are not in support of the Dual
roles which I kind of think you guys are
not um I do say the DRC and the pick
I've only been the chair for one meeting
and ran very smoothly just want to add
that um but I did talk with somebody
that was on the committee and she's been
on the committee for eight years I
personally feel that I'm a I'm a parent
advocate through pick so I've done their
training which is an amazing
organization as well as a DRC but I've
been told that in the last eight years
that there was a member on they have not
produced any information or any data so
I think they have a wealth of
information but how do we get them to
share it with us because without that
data and without that information it's
not overly helpful so again I've only
had one committee meeting so my hope
would be that there are going to share
that data in the future and I have not
personally asked them if they're willing
to I just don't know they just never
have in the last eight years to my
knowledge thank you yes represent bony
thank you Mr chair um would would you
say that uh you've been given adequate
support from the Department of Education
to help the
this group achieve its Mission no um as
far as the as far as the clerk goes we
we were able to find somebody that is
apparent that has stepped up to take our
minute so that's fine um the internet
too I don't know if that's an issue but
I I also want to make sure I address
that but we did ask um Rebecca fet from
the due at our last meeting if we had
any funds because we wanted somebody to
come and help us with a direction um to
help us find our our purpose because
again I think we all realize we're not
very functionable right now which we're
not um and the comment that was made to
me was you have no money we have money
but you have no money um and I think we
were asking for under it was a little
about $600 for somebody to come and help
us with our goal we're a parent L
committee and and again I'm a
Schoolboard member of my town I you know
I work for an area agency you know we're
knowledgeable but we need direction and
without any kind of funds we're it we're
kind of stuck which is
unfortunate um I'd also like to address
the internet it was brought up that we
have a remote option in the last year
before I was the chair our remote option
is is absolutely deplorable in my
opinion um you were there at the last
committee so I think that you would back
this up per the law it states that you
have to be able to hear and be heard if
you're on a remote option that was not
possible we're given the Facility by the
doe so they give us the meeting place
which is in conquered and then they're
all supposed to set up the Wi-Fi and in
the last year that I've been on the
committee it's pretty much always been
an issue um September I don't believe
was an issue but June was an issue it
our remote option and our remote access
is just not feasible for a full
committee to be able to have a remote
option so that that's a really big
concern for some of our parents because
as you know you've stated parents are
unfortunately dealing with their
children with a disability or they have
you know illnesses and so having that
remote option is really important for us
and it's it's again you were there it it
option we got some hands up here sorry
uh represent Dy then represent Cornell
then back represent Bon uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you for answering these
questions thank you um
are your 16 positions filled right now
with
parents um I think we have 15 but our
parents don't show up a lot so it would
be great if we had more because again
these parents are working they're
dealing with personal issues and with
disabilities so when you only have the
bare minimum of what makes up your
parent majority you're probably never
going to get a committee where it's a
parent majority in voting okay follow up
please yeah uh so it's not really a
question of needing to find more parents
to add it's just being them being able
to be there well if you have 22
positions that are currently non-parents
and you have 16 positions at our parents
you don't even need that majority yeah
math doesn't really support that thank
you thank you representative Cornell now
that the doe is in the process or have
already moved into the building where I
think they allow you to have your
meetings might not the video get maybe
hopefully better so the meeting we had
last month has been the meeting that
we've used in the last year so I don't
think that's the factor where where are
you meeting Granite State College at the
State College yeah okay yeah and and by
the way I just we do ask ahead of time
if if the internet and everything is
going to be good and we're told yes and
then when we get there it's kind of
a I don't want to use the term but you
know what I'm
saying reer you know um I hate to say
this but I think there's an elephant in
the room that nobody's addressing and
that is a lack of resources for this
committee correct so to me it's not the
number that are there it's it's the
whole approach to dealing with this
committee and and that's not addressed
in the law in the uh in the amendment
that's here so it's I think we see this
often times before the committee where
you've got other issues that are out
there that can't be addressed by by it
and it would seem to me as represent Bon
said you know without the kind of
resources that should be available for
the committee whether it be internet
whether it be staff whatever it doesn't
make any difference who's on that
committee because they're not going to
show up if it's not going to function
right and obviously it needs some it
needs some assistance and with the
federal dollars that come into the
department it was sure as how same to me
that there ought to be some money put
aside so this so this group could in
fact function and so I guess that's my
frustration as I've looked at listen to
this conversation it's not the numbers
it's clear the numbers are an issue no
question but it goes Way Beyond the
issue of the functionality of this
particular committee and not having the
right governmental support to make sure
that they can meet their mission and I
would like to add to that you are 100%
correct and I support everything you
just said if you're a parent who's been
on the committee and we have called
parent so I I this is this is truthful
when you call a parent and they're
working hard and they're they're taking
care of their kids and they go to
committee and it's just not functioning
how much of your time do you waste
because there's so many other things
that they can do and they want to take
their time and they want to join a
committee and then in the past year that
I've been on it was either run for chair
or step down so hopefully this is going
to be the change that we have and and we
do have some really good parents that
are on there but how do we get those
parents re-engaged to be able to move
forward when you don't have any funds to
help you be able to move forward it's
that VIs to Circle so thank you for
presenting that it's I I'd like to just
cut in on this I'm looking at the
membership on the council is there a
member on this Council from the
Department of Education special
education correct Rebecca
forette okay I'm trying to find out
where she's located on this Litany of
people I it's on my phone I can grab
it which which part of the state
positions what read it what what's it
say St
education well okay that doesn't do it
for me uh it doesn't say from the
Department of Education technical
support or something such as that I've
been over at the department when there
has been a member on the committee that
provides technical support or is a
voting
member the the rooms are always set up
and ready to go because there is a
person from the Department that's
participating on that
Council our Council uh representative
Cornell is always done well our all the
Committees for for for CTE are done
right when we've been over there for
other issues dealing with uh Safety and
Security in schools it's always done
correctly so I think the error that we
have done as a legislator we haven't
said that there's an individual from the
Department of Education appointed by the
commissioner I don't see that on this at
all
you appointed by the state by the
governor that that's that doesn't
there's no accountability in that
whereas if we have somebody like a Jeff
beard or we have somebody like Steve
applebe who's there on that committee
then I think we're going to tie in all
your money issues are there y taken care
of your place to meet is there you're
streaming and everything online is taken
care of Pardon Me
18 I think that this is something has to
be amended into the bill and I think
represent my is correct that we haven't
hit what the issue is here and I think
this one way to get around it is it a
problem that they meet at 5:00 and that
that that used to be the big problem
they used to meet on Thursday afternoons
at 4:00 right in the middle of session
and legislators could never never attend
because you leave the hall and it's a
close vote you you can't leave that it's
also difficult for parents to especially
parents that are working to come at I
don't mean you should go during the day
I mean having someone from the
Department saying you have to stay at
5:00 for the
meeting that that that is so yes and if
I if I could um the the entire time I
was on and since then um the special
education director has been a member of
the committee and in addition I think um
on occasion Melissa white from division
of instruction um also attends the
meetings so there is no lack of
Department of Education um participation
anyway on the
council I think what we're going to have
to do before we go much further
represent Miler and I both have a
meeting starting up at one
o'clock uh and I don't even know where
that
is 101 downstairs okay or no that's in
the other bill down downstairs so we're
not getting through this today but we're
going to have to have some coming
together and trying to fix this uh so
maybe what I ought to do right now is a
point a smaller group to try to nail
this thing down so when we do come back
a working group just you know maybe at
Max five people we don't want a lot of
people uh just to try pardon me
24 is there anybody like to be on a
working group and to try to nail down a
little
bit represent B you have your hand up um
yeah I think that um thank you sir Mr
chair um that both probably both I'm
probably speaking for representative
Tanner but we've already started this so
we we'd be more than happy to continue
to try to reach is there anybody like to
work with representa Tanner and
represent Balon and trying to come back
with some because we're going to meet
one more time in that on this that's
going to be it because then we're going
to have November 13th right on top of us
that's just right around the corner so
this anybody else would like to work on
um you could do it I'm not saying how to
do it just get it
done I'll okay folks come up with
something really please can can we find
out I know when Jeff comes to our
meetings he also brings technical help
with him from his from his Department
within the department so it I don't know
if if Becky is always going to the means
if she could bring
someone administrative strative help
with her what what the problem has been
is that Granite State is their home now
but it's just recently they've had areas
within that building leased out to other
organizations and their leases weren't
up and so now they're closing and the
building is becoming more of one
building and with that the technical
people are able to get in and give
assistance uh I I think what we've got
is if we can get like a director or an
individual like Becky fet as the person
she then has the ability to pull in the
technical support there and I know
that's what Steve and that's what Jeff
do uh so it another director could do
the saying um so I don't think it's
really where we have
to I think the support is there it's
just it's got to come internally from do
doe to make sure things are set up
properly um there's you know the the
legislative youth advisory Council too
you're familiar with that one where they
come up with legislation and all that
that's always never had support either
the one that's always had to run that
was um Susan uh representative out of
where she at sugar Hill
or Su Ford and so but these this is a
notch up though this is a a group which
really does need support I think we can
do it and I appreciate it if you look at
making sure that it's really defined in
this legislation that a person there is
whether they're voting or not I don't
care but they need to have the technical
support has to be
there from from the Department amen okay
so let's I got four minutes to eat my
lunch
and I I you can but I'm not going to be
able to be here for that you know it's
it's just you know I know Mel and I have
to get out of here and I think we both
have some things we got to do prior to
that so um I would advise if there is
somebody that from the audience who
wants to give some input contact
represent cascaden or represent Balon or
representa Tanner that are going to be
working on this and and so we can get
something we will with the other bills
the time to be announced will be
announced we'll look at the calendar see
when we can meet but you got about a
week or so here to get going on that
we're running out of
time thank you very much we're going to
have to close this thing down people are
yes
last